pu à mon image au
moi
attends ben je sais pas dirv désolé je
sais pas pour le pigar
pour le
cigar
bonne
journée
malement
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans les studio
du Figaro et bienvenue ici place de
l'Esplanade des Invalides une marche
contre
l'antisémitisme une nouvelle marche on
va y revenir toute l'après-midi une
partie de la soirée sur ceciite sur le
site du Figaro où vous nous suivez et
bien sûr sur la page Youtube du Figaro
vous suivez avec nous vous commentez
vous respectez bien évidemment les
chares te de modération surtout sur un
sujet aussi sensible plusieurs
manifestations 73 manifestations et déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de monde plusieurs
milliers de personnes qui ont été vu
aperçu 3000 à Lyon 3000 à Strasbourg il
y a également des manifestations dans le
sud à Nice on va y
revenir à Paris ça va commencer d'ici
une vingtaine de minutes maintenant
c'est là qu'on retrouve Vincent roseron
bonjour Vincent un des tests un des
enjeux c'est la mobilisation est-ce que
à l'heure actuelle on voit sur vos
images est-ce qu'il y a déjà du
monde alors il y a déjà du monde la
manifestation n'a pas encore démarré
puisqu'elle prendra son départ à 15h
mais il y a déjà du monde sur
l'esplanade des Invalides on rappelle
que cette place des Invalides cette
esplanade est vraiment gigantesque et
donc forcément là ça sur les images ça
peut vous paraître un peu désert
forcément mais il y a déjà pas mal de
monde qui sont présents pour l'instant
lors de cette manifestation vous voyez à
côé en face sur les images le DOM des
Invalides une pancarte en face avec le
CRIF et des responsables politiques qui
sont pour l'instant de l'autre côté vers
le pont qui est ici avec par exemple des
responsables de la gauche qui sont
arrivés marine Tondelier Olivier fort et
Fabien
Roussel merci beaucoup Vincent alors je
nous on vous entendait pas mais on va on
va régler ça euh et euh mais j'espère
que les internautes nous entendent vous
pouvez commenter en direct ces images
qui nous parviennent on sera en direct
également grâce aux images que nous nous
apporter vont nous apporter l'Agence
France Presse à partir de 14h également
des images en région notamment à
Marseille bonjour Gilles Smadja bonjour
vous êtes euh avec nous vous êtes un
ancien directeur de cabinet du du maire
de Nanterre ancien directeur de cabinet
de marie-jorge buffet et ancien
journaliste autrefois euh à à l'humanité
ça fait beaucp beaucoup autrement dit
vous avez connu toute cette la gauche la
gauche dur également vous connaissez et
vous vous allez manifester aujourd'hui
bien sûr
pourquoi le nom que je porte est inscrit
sur le mémorial de la Choa à Paris parmi
les 76000 noms de de Juifs de France qui
ont été déporté assassiné dans les camps
durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale le la
l'engagement la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme ça fait partie de l'ADN
de mon engagement depuis toujours et la
situation aujourd'hui est gravissime
elle est gravissime parce que
aujourd'hui parmi les les Juifs de
France et j'en connais beaucoup il y a
un sentiment d'inquiétude parfois de
peur et surtout un sentiment d'isolement
et d'abandon je crois que l'abandon
c'est peut-être le pire mais cette ce
sentiment d'isolement et d'abandon
g est-ce qu'il est justifié au regard
justement de la mobilisation qu'il y a
aujourd'hui de la lettre qu' adresser
ces dernières heures le président de la
République en avec des mots très forts
je je lis notamment pas de tolérance
pour
l'intolérable
des la place de l'antisémitisme est
devant les tribunaux et derrière les les
barreaux l'engagement en tous les cas au
plus haut niveau de l'État est clair lui
il était temps il était temps quand vous
pensez que les les actes antisémites se
sont déchaînés à partir du 7 octobre le
7 le 8 le 9 ça n'a pas arrêté depuis et
il a fallu attendre un mois le 7
novembre pour que et merci et tant mieux
pour que les présidents des deux hautes
assemblées de notre pays décident de
cette marche qui a lieu aujourd'hui et
lance cet appel dans les dans les
colonnes de fig du Figaro cette semaine
euh avec qui vous allez manifester
aujourd'hui Gill avec ma famille mes
amis
les gens que que je connais voilà je
crois qu'on n pas besoin d'être derrière
une banderole on n pas besoin d'être
derrière un un parti politique ou une
obédience on va manifester parce qu'on
on on rejette l'antisémitisme parce que
l'antisémitisme est une est peut-être ce
qui a mis notre pays dans la pire des
pages de son histoire il y a quelques
dizaines d'années et donc le voilà on n
pas besoin d'être de manifester pour
soutenir telle ou telle étiquette ou je
ne sais quoi est-ce que la présence du
RN vous
gêne je ne suis pas dupe je ne suis pas
dupe je sais parfaitement que cette
présence n'a absolument rien à voir avec
les convictions profondes les origines
les objectifs l'histoire l'héritage de
ce mouvement politique ce mouvement
politique s'est fondé sur la
collaboration avec le nazisme il est il
a une filiation avec les antisémites de
de toujours euh le leond le le le
fondateur de de ce mouvement Jean-Marie
Le Pen a été condamné à de multiples
reprises pour négationnisme donc voilà
je ne suis pas DUP après pour moi ça
n'est pas le sujet je crois qu'il a été
condamné sans doute à plusieurs reprises
je suis pas sûr que soit pour
négationisme oui enfin il a été condamné
pour incitation à la haine je sais plus
enfin exactement le motif mais c'était
euh on va quand même pas rappeler les
les les galéjades de Jean-Marie Le Pen
Durafour crématoire les les chambres à
gaz qui étaient un point de détail Mar
Le Pen répond aujourd'hui dans les
colonnes du du GDD que effectivement il
y a pu avoir un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont frayé avec la colon
caboration dans la création du Fran
national mais ça été le cas dans
d'autres parties et elle rappelle
également en tous les cas
soulligne qu'il y a eu également de
grands résistants qui ont participé à la
fondation de son parti oui mais moi j'ai
lu des enquêtes d'opinion très récentes
qui montre que c'est dans l'électorat
qui se reconnaît qui vote pour le
rassemblement national que les idées
antisémites sont encore les plus
présente que les les clichés qui
s'appliquent à qui s'appliquent à
l'antisémitisme c'està-dire les Juifs
font tous les pouvoirs ils sont
puissants ils sont riches enfin tout ce
qu'on peut entendre c'est dans cet
électorat là que que on on pense le plus
ce ce type qu'on est qu'on a le plus ce
type de préjugés alors c'est intéressant
ce que dit parce que c'est quand même
pas ce qu'on entend en tous les cas de
la la plupart de de responsables de la
de la communauté de la communauté juive
notamment des responsables buchf ou bien
de de grandes figures morales comme
Serge classfel dans les colonnes du
Figaro cette
semaine et qui non seulement euh en tout
cas soulligne que Marine Le Pen a rompu
avec le passé de son du parti et et en
particulier avec les déclarations de son
père mais également mettre en cause une
autre une autre mouvance que vous
connaissez bien qui est la gauche
radicale ah mais je j'en suis meurtri de
voir à quel point aujourd'hui les idées
antisémite euh parfois la haine des
Juifs j'en je suis meurtri de voir que
ça pénètre aujourd'hui une partie de la
gauche effectivement ça c'est c'est vrai
mais il n'en reste pas moins que pour
moi si vous voulez la stratégie de
Madame Le Pen c'est une stratégie
électorale qui vise à à essayer de de se
dédiaboliser de s'honorabiliser pour
être une prétendante crédible à la
présidence de la République voilà c'est
ça n'est ça n'est rien d'autre que ça je
encore une fois je je pense qu'il ne
faut pas il faut il faut rester les yeux
grands ouverts sur ce qu'est le
rassemblement national
on va revenir également donc sur l'autre
en tout cas l'autreit fait politique
c'est l'absence de la France insoumise à
cette à cette manifestation d'abord Gill
qu'est-ce que vous inspire les les
derniers propos de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
tenu sur Twitter concernant cette
manifestation je les cite hein dimanche
manif de l'arc républicain arc
républicain entre guillemets du RN à la
macronique de Bron pivé et sous prétexte
d'antisémitisme ramène Israël Palestine
sans demander le cesser le feu les amis
du soutien inconditionnel au massacre
ont leur rendez-vous c'est ignoble et
c'est grave parce que ça veut dire ce
que dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça veut dire
que cet après-midi les gens qui vont
marcher sont des gens qui vont marcher
pour soutenir les bombardements à Gaza
c'est-à-dire ce rapprochement qui est
fait
entre juif de France égal Israël égal
soutien au bombardement à Gaza mais
c'est précisément ça qui est à l'origine
des actes antisémites c'est ça justement
le problème c'est-à-dire que le le fait
de de considérer que les Juifs de France
sont
responsables de ce qui se passe de tous
les actes de du gouvernement c'est ça
l'importation du conflit complètement
mais complètement c'estàdire c'est
d'amalgamer les Juifs de France avec la
politique d'Israël et de considérer que
l'antisémitisme les actes antisémites en
France ne sont que la conséquence le
prix à payer en quelque sorte de ce qui
se passe là-bas est est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce est- question question à l'ancien
journaliste de l'UMA que vous êtes
est-ce qu'on peut critiquer Israël
l'actuelle opération actuellement menée
par par Israël je pose une question de
principe et à les manifester mais
évidemment mais j'en connais beaucoup
qui qui ont cette attitude vous savez
moi je suis très critique vis-à-vis du
gouvernement israélien même si
aujourd'hui je pense que la guerre
contre le Hamas est nécessaire je suis
extrêmement critique je fais partie de
ces Juifs de France qui considèrent que
Monsieur netanahou doit être
jugé par une commission d'enquête sur ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre il doit
être jugé sanctionné destitué comme
l'avait été un certain nombre de
dirigeants voilà donc oui bien sûr qu'on
peut mais la la la marche aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas une marche de soutien à Israël
ça n'est pas une marche de pour exprimer
telle ou telle opinion sur ce qui se
passe au moyen-orin c'est une on peut
parfaitement être opposé à au
gouvernement israélien et aller
manifester aujourd'hui pour dire NON
l'antisémitisme pas ça pas pas ça c'est
grave est-ce que néanmoins
l'antisionisme et en particulier à
gauche n'est pas un
paravant parfois monsieursieur pour pour
cacher quand même des sentiments et en
tout cas des idées vraiment antis si on
avait un doute là-dessus Monsieur
Mélenchon l'a levé le doute puisque pour
lui vous pensez que Mélenchon est
antisémite non pas du tout je ne dis pas
ça du tout je l'ai moi je l'ai entendu
mais c'était il y a longtemps je l'ai
entendu des dire des choses magnifique
sur l'émancipation des Juifs de France
sous la Révolution française et tout ça
je l'ai entendu dire dire des choses
extrêmement intelligentes et extrêmement
fortes mais je crois qu'il est dans une
dérive dans une stratégie purement
électoraliste voilà il espère que ça va
lui attirer des voix je pense qu'il
commet une très lourde erreur outre que
c'est une faute morale je pense qu'il
commet une très lourde erreur parce que
il va peut-être grapiller quelqu vois
ici là il va en perdre beaucoup à
commencé par la mienne et donc je pense
que voilà ça n'est pas mais mais mais
non il n pas sémite mais en revanche il
est dans une dérive qui est absolument
incroyable et pour lui effectivement
aujourd'hui lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est soutenir Israël et
ça c'est totalement inacceptable euh ce
matin euh la France insoumise a organisé
euh une manifestation un hommage aux
victimes du de la rafle du veldive et
cette cette mobilisation a été perturbé
par un certain nombre de de manifestants
qui ont reproché euh à la France
insoumise de confisquer la mémoire et
d'instrumentaliser la mémoire quel est
votre commentaire par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé ce matin moi je les
comprends ces manifestant l'arave du
valdive on la commémore chaque année au
mois de juillet c'està-d à la date où a
eu lieu la rave du valdiv pourquoi
bricoler comme ça à la dernière minute
ce matin un acte de mais vous vous vous
faites pas euh vous faites pas acte à à
la france insouise d' non c'est
complètement politicien c'était une
façon de vous savez ils sont ils sont
marqué dans une dans une attitude
évidemment dont il mesure la la gravité
et les conséquences qu'elle peut avoir
parce que ne pas être dans un une un
rassemblement républicain contre
l'antisémitisme moi je pense que ça aura
de lourdes conséquences pour l'avenir de
la France insoumise et de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et donc évidemment comme il
ils ont un peu conscience de de ce
problème alors ils bricolent au dernier
moment un truc là des fleurs ici tout ça
mais tout ça est est assez dérisoire et
quand même un peu pathétique parce que
d'aller devant le devant le monument du
veldive
franchement moi ça me gêne et je je suis
assez mal à l'aise par rapport à ça euh
il y a également un certain nombre de
questions chalu Rico qui nous nous
rejoint et qui pose une question
précisément sur une autre polémique et
qui concerne la France insoui cette
semaine c'est celle concernant l'ancien
responsable de de du mouvement de
jeuness de la France insist David
guireud qui fait des déclarations qui
ont suscité pas mal de de de
commentaires pas mal de polémiques lors
d'un voyage en Tunisie où il dit les
bébés massacrés c'est Israël les femmes
éventré c'est Israël Sabra et Chatila
c'est
Israël ce midi manuel Bompard qui était
l'invité de de BFM a dit qu'il voyait
pas pourquoi il sanctionnerait David
guerot bah on a l'impression qu'il y a
un concours qui qui s'est qui a été créé
au sein de la France insoumise pour
savoir celui qui dirait le plus
d'horreur entre madame auonau monsieur
guireud madame Panau voilà on a
l'impression qu'ils sont dans une dans
un concours entre eux pour savoir B non
il faudrait que toi tu dises encore plus
de trucs dur contre les Juifs contre
Israël tout ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
pathétique franchement c'est lamentable
et c'est assez pathétique
euh je reviens sur l'autre phénomène
celui dont on parlait sur la présence du
du RN pour vous ça marque pas un
tournant vous pensez que le qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de l'interview de
Serge clarfell dans le Figaro bon bah
vous savez euh oui il y a un certain
nombre de de figures de la communauté
juive de France dont Monsieur clarsfield
qui est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai une
grande admiration fait partie qui qui
ont cette opinion là ce n'est pas la
mienne et ce n'est et ce n'est pas non
plus celle de très nombreux de très
nombreux amis juifs de France qui ne qui
qui ne veulent absolument pas croire à
autre chose
qu'à une attitude électoraliste de la
part de Madame Le Pen Madame Le Pen
justement Marine Le Pen en tous les cas
qui est actuellement qui vient d'arriver
devant les Invalides à l'heure actuelle
entouré de députés du rassemblement
national on a notamment vu Sébastien
Chenu on va peut-être écouter s'il y a
une déclaration est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet euh vous l'avez dit vous êtes
inquiet de la montée de l'antisémitisme
moi j'ai une question à l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de Marie-George
Buffet vous êtes dans Le Parisien le
champion paralympique Michael jéréias
dénonce je cite le silence coupable du
milieu sportif est-ce que l'admirateur
de Mohamed Ali que vous êtes
ne partage pas la souffrance de Michel
jéréiaaz si bien sûr que je la partage
pourquoi le milieu sportif est alors il
y a l'anturam sera présent à cette à
cette manifestation l'ancien
footballeur
mais pourquoi le milieu sportif est
aussi
silencieux je pense que c'est ça reflète
bien aujourd'hui une partie de de l'état
de l'opinion
c'est-à-dire un certain nombre de
sportifs qui ont quand même plutôt qui
se sont engagés ces derniers temps sur
diverses causes euh contre le racisme
contre voilà et ben ils doivent
considérer que lutter contre
l'antisémitisme joindre leur voix à ce
rassemblement c'est soutenir Israël et
évidemment je pense que c'est ça qui est
le problème numéro 1 aujourd'hui et et
et d'autant que quand il voit un certain
nombre il y a un anticianisme très fort
dans les milieux sportif c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de me dire ben je
pense qu'il y a l'idée que Israël est
responsable de à peu près tous les
malheurs du monde quoi oui je pense que
cette idéelà elle est partagée par
malheureusement trop de gens bon il y a
quand même quelques exceptions le
gardien le très grand gardien de but du
Real Madrid courtois qui est le gardien
de l'équipe de
Belgique il a il a pris position contre
l'antisémitisme de manière très ouverte
ça lui a valu un certain nombre de
réflexion mais mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut que un peu se désoler
de ce silence mais vous savez il y a pas
que chez les sportifs he chez les
artistes aussi hein qui est quand même
qui est quand même encore plus étonnant
peut-être parce que bon on peut dire que
dans le Milie certain d'artistes ont
fait quand même un certain nombre de
déclarations notamment chez nos
confrères du
Parisien où on voit quand même une
certaine mobilisation notamment on a vu
tout à l'heure
akiou ouiah
oui deux artistes de confession juive
est-ce que cette manifestation peut
faire vraiment reculer l'antisémitisme
elle aura en tout cas une vertu c'est
qu'elle montrera à au juifs de France
qu'ils ne sont pas seuls qu'ils ne sont
pas abandonnés que la République est est
est avec eux et que euh il ne faut pas
avoir peur voilà ce n'est pas à nous
d'avoir peur c'est à ceux qui commettent
ces actes c'est eux qui doivent avoir
peur de la justice
euh il y a eu Carpentra c'était le 24
mai 1990 la manifestation après la mort
d'Ilan Alimi en en 2006 Ilan Alimi
c'était ce jeune juif qui a été
cerquestré torturé à mort par le ce
qu'on appelait le gang des barbares
Youssouf Fofana ressortant gunvoirienne
et la l'assassinat de mirriel knol en en
mars 2018 et la manifestation qui avait
suivi on voit qu'il y a des manif des
marche blanche mais que les actes
continuent vous le disiez 1240 hein
depuis le le 7 mars autant en un mois
qu'en un an est-ce que ça sert à quelque
chose euh vous savez euh vous vous avez
rappelé trois faits c'est intéressant de
noter que après carpenta il y avait eu
une manifestation gigantesque président
de la République en tête des centaines
de milliers de personnes des millions à
travers la France après ilanalimi il y
en avait beaucoup moins il y en avait
30000 à Paris après madame knol il y en
avait encore moins quelques milliers et
donc aujourd'hui il était temps et je
crois que tout ça a contribué à
banaliser l'antisémitisme c'est-à-dire à
créer ce sentiment d'impunité on peut
s'en prendre à des Juifs on peut
attaquer quelqu'un qui porte une kipa on
peut euh euh jeter un cocktail Molotof
contre une synagogue et on pense que il
ne il il ne nous arrivera il les ceux
qui font ça pensent qu'il ne leur
arrivera pas grand-chose il était temps
de dire stop ça suffit j'espère que
cette journée d'aujourd'hui va un petit
peu remettre tout ça dans le bon sens et
va va remettre la justice au cœur au
cœur de cette démarche 33 euh ministres
manifestent il y a une une une dont une
quinzaine d'ailleurs en région est-ce
que le gouvernement fait assez non mais
c'est franchement moi je c'est peu
importe c'est pas très important ça ce
qui est ce qui est le plus important
c'est combien il y aura de citoyens dans
les rues aujourd'hui combien il y aura
de Français qui se sentiront concerné
quelle que soit leur opinion quelle que
soit leur confession par le le fait de
soutenir les Français juifs pour leur
dire vous n'êtes pas seul on est à vos
côtés on n'accepte pas que quelqu'un
s'en prenne un juif pour la seule raison
qu'il est juif c'est ça l'antisémitisme
il faut le rappeler sans cesse vous
parliez de la montée de l'antisémitisme
surtout depuis
1990 Gill est-ce que vous avez vu
vous-même vous avez été au première loge
vous avez été directeur de ma du maire
de cabinet lentaire est-ce que vous avez
vu monter l'anti tisme dans les banliers
et en particulier là à Nanterre pas
spécialement à Nanterre mais oui je l'ai
vu monter dans dans les quartiers
populaire bien sûr
l'antisémitisme ben oui vous savez
l'antisémitisme il est il est distilé
H24 sur d'un certain nombre de médias
par exemple aljazera et Cap mal regarder
dans un certain nombre de quartiers al
si vous voulez aujourd'hui pour un C
est-ce que justement pardon je vous
passer la question très directement G
mais euh en 1990 est-ce qu'on s'est pas
trompé de combat on a stigmatisé un
antisémitisme d'extrême droite en disant
que c'était la menace principale et 10
ans plus tard à partir de la deuxème
Intifada on voit que cet antisémitisme
il est pas dans il il reste résiduel
dans C dans cette mouvance et il est
monté dans un dans dans une tendance
qu'on avait pas du tout voulu vu ou
voulu voir oui alors peut-être peut-être
qu'on a sous-estimé effectivement mais
vous savez il faut se garder de tous les
moi je lis attentivement tout ce qui
sort aujourd'hui sur les gens qui
comparaissent devant les tribunaux pour
des actes antisémites c'est pas
forcément que le profil du jeune de
quartier de banlieu c'est pas que ça
vous savez la la personne qui a
travaillé au ké d'orsé qui qui a arraché
les affiches des
otages du Hamas c'est pas c'est pas une
jeune d'un quartier he donc faut il faut
aussi faire attention à moi bien sûr
c'est diplomatique donc c'était pas
cétait pas la droite dur non plus ouais
ou donc faut faire attention bon
évidemment ça existe il faut le
combattre et j'ai beaucoup d'amis
musulmans dans les quartiers qui
combattent aussi l'antisémitisme
mais reste que là quand même les
dignitaires musulmans sont très peu
représentés à cette c'est regrettable
c'est regrettable à la différence de des
des responsables catholiques notamment
l'évêque de nanre qui est présent à
cette manifestation fait merci beaucoup
Gill SMAN bah on va vous le voyez
dispositif de sécurité devant
l'Assemblée nationale
où doit passer le le cortage on va re
rejoindre Vincent roseron et je vous
laisse rejoindre Vincent roseron et les
personnes qui sont à cette manifestation
merci d'être passé par les studi du
Figaro Gilles et à très bientôt on
continuera bien entendu de de commenter
et merci en tous les cas pour vos
réponses franches et vos explications
Vincent reoseron la manifestation
s'apprête à partir ou elle est peut-être
déjà parti là où vous
êtes
alors pour l'instant de ce que je vois
elle s'apprête plutôt à partir plutôt
que de partir il y
a quel côté va partir cette
manifestation et donc on va peut-être
recevoir
revoir de la
mobilisation en tout cas du dispositif
de sécurité pendant que Albert Zenou
prend place dans les studios du Figaro
quand les images figent c'est le signe
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde on a vu
quand même plusieurs milliers de
personnes notamment en région on va
continuer de suivre ça je salue Mayday
qui nous
euh rejoint et qui a ce mot d'esprit qui
est l'antisémitisme n'est plus un métier
en tension on peut arrêter d'en importer
bonjour Albert Zenou bonjour vous êtes
rédacteur en chef au service politique
du Figaro rédacteur en chef du service
politique
et on va continuer à suivre ce qui nous
arrive on va commenter les les
différentes images et peut-être faire
des arrêts quand il y aura des des
déclarations Emmanuel Macron a renoncé à
venir mais n'est pas resté silencieux si
on peut dire non il
a il a é cré au français une lettre que
le Parisien a reproduit hier soir et
dans son édition d'aujourd'hui où il où
il il il il donne son sentiment il est
il fait partie de ces Français qui
veulent qui soutiennent la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme même s'ils ne participe
pas physiquement à cette marche il a il
a amené des arguments il a amené des
choses alors beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
compris pourquoi il ne participaient pas
alors même que Nicolas Sarkozi François
Hollande ancien ancien président de la
République eux vont participer François
Hollande a participé à une manifestation
après les après les attentats du du
Bataclan et les per
cachè en tant que en tant que président
en exercice il avait participé donc
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas compris cette
cette position qui est peut-être un peu
difficile d'autant que dans un premier
temps hier en tous les cas euh auprès
d'une descendante de du capitaine dfus
capitaine drefus oui pardon il avait dit
des des mots un peu un peu pas ambigu
mais il pouvait laisser penser que
c'était c'était euh euh une division il
ne voulait pas participer à la à la
manifestation parce que ça remettait
peut-être en cause l'unité du pays
l'unité nationale donc c'était donc ça
traduit une hésitation quand même
àaliser hein oui bien sûr mais bien sûr
on a beaucoup débattu il y a eu beaucoup
de délibération autour de cette
de cette de cette venue de cette de
cette question oui parce qu'on ne savait
pas pendant longtemps on n pas su s'il
allait s'il allait être présent ou pas
la manifestation on ne le savait pas
mais la question c'est est-ce que
lui-même a longtemps hésité ou pas
est-ce que son entourage a beaucoup
hésité apparemment ça en donne en tout
cas l'impression oui ça il y avait il il
y avait des choses on peut comprendre
que le le président de la République est
dans un souci d'équilibre qu' ne veut
pas donner trop d'un côté ou d'un
l'autre on a on lui a reproché certains
lui ont reproché et d'être d'avoir été
un un soutien très appuyé euh euh
d'Israël dans son combat après le après
le le 7 octobre et ensuite être revenu
sur une notion un peu plus équilibrée et
notamment ce qu'il a dit à la BBC hier
où il il appelle à un cesser le feu
immédiat en en ne faisant pas référence
forcément de façon explicite aux otages
notamment français qui sont toujours
détenus par le Hamas et et euh et tous
les Françis et tous les Français tous
les et tous les Israéliens qui sont
morts le ce ce jour-là donc cette cette
position d'équilibre est toujours un peu
compliquée c'est un peu le en même temps
qu bah oui c'est ce que dit Chardon Bleu
Macron fait du en même temps comme
d'habitude alors Chardon Bleu regrette
et et dénonce un manque de courage de la
part du du Président c'est un c'est un
choix qui est toujours en un peu bizarre
de la part du président de la République
c'est qu'il avance sur un sur un chemin
mais quel que soit le sujet hein souvent
c'est dans là c'est dans la diplomatie
mais sur en économie en sociale peu un
peu dans dans tous les domaines il
avance sur un sujet puis ensuite il
revient sur il repasse sur un autre un
autre mode il revient il il navigue
entre entre deux eau souvent et qui rend
qui rend son son discours et son et son
parcours un peu un
peu pas invisible mais difficilement
décryptable on ne comprend pas bien
quelle est la position exacte de la
France ce qui ce qui est intéressant
alors ça c'est sur la question
internationale mais sur la question
politique en tous les cas je je je
reviens sur ce que vous disiez à
l'instant c'était cette hésitation en
tous les cas qu' a exprimé devant la la
famille du capitaine drefus euh en se
demandant s'il allait pas une présence
pour être un un ferm de division c'est
d'autant plus curieux que quand même
tous les sondages on va y revenir un peu
plus longuement tout à l'heure avec
Véronique rult de président de bbon
Consulting mais le sondage bbon odoxa
pour Le Figaro publié dans les pages du
Figaro ce vendredi montre que il il y a
en tous les cas une forte majorité de
Français qui soutient cette marche
sondage d'ailleurs également fait par
nos confrères du JDD qui lui donne le
soutien enfin fait état du soutien dans
les mêmes dans les mêmes
chifr% y a il y a une vraie majorité
forte qui soutient cette cette cette
démarche il faut rappeler que cette
cette manifestation à
l'organisation l'initiative plutôt de de
du président du Sénat Gerard Larcher et
de la président de l'Assemblée il y a
une rôle privée est est une marche pour
la République et contre l'antisémitisme
ce n'est pas un soutien d's regardez
d'ailleurs on a des imag à Marseille
actuellement la mobilisation également
il y a 73 rassemblements en tout
aujourd'hui et voici donc les images qui
nous parviennent de de la cité fosséenne
où il y a plusieurs milliers de
personnes plusieurs milliers de
personnes également qui sont signalées à
Lyon à Strasbourg également
rassemblement à Nice et puis à Paris on
reviendra et on retrouvera Vincent
roseron tout à l'heure euh Albert
pourquoi euh il a elbron Pivet et Gérard
Larcher euh ont choisi ont voulu faire
cette cette manifestation alors vous
allez me dire que parce qu'il trouvent
qu'il y a trop d'actes antisémit et
cetera c'est ce qu'il marquent dans leur
tribune mais quel est
euh finalement mais qu'est-ce qui a les
a décidé il les a décidé à faire cet
appel cet appel conjoint en dehors de la
proximité des ivelines dont ils sont
tous les deux
non je pense pas que je pense pas que
cette proximité était on laoué en plus
c'est pas à côté joué un grand rôle non
si les
deux le 2e et le 3è quasiment dans
l'ordre protocolaire personnage de
l'État ont décidé d'gager C cette
manifestation c'est parce qu'ils avaient
le sentiment outre le fait qu'il y avait
une recrudissance prodigieuse et
incroyable du nombre d'actes antisémites
mais parce que ils avaient le ils ont eu
le sentiment et le et et je crois que
c'est partagé par beaucoup de gens que
les les les Français juifs avaient le
sentiment d'être un peu isolés d'être un
peu d'être un peu laissé seul il y avait
qu'il y avait certes des
manifestations àelant enfin pro plutôt
proalestiniennes qui il y avait dans
mais que il ne sentait pas que dans dans
l'opinion française en tous les cas
alors que les sondages leur donnaient
plutôt raison alors que il n'y avait pas
un soutien fort et massif et là et qu'il
y avait pas eu cette ce réveil de
conscience C cette cet appel à à
soutenir les Français juifs dans ce
combat contre l'antisémitisme on dit pas
contre contre le ramas ou contre contre
la Palestine c'est contre contre les
actes antisémites en France réalisant en
France et donc que que ce soi deux
personnes issues de camp politiques
différents puisque il y a une problème
privé
et et Renaissance donc majorité
présidentielle plutôt venue plutôt de la
gauche et gerérard Larché est est un LR
pur et dur donc de la droite de la
droite républicaine que les deux
personnage de l'État B pur etd dur il
est elle est en tous les cas il a il a
jamais il n'a jamais tergiversé il n'a
jamais il na jamais euh en tous les cas
officiellement il non il na jamais il
n'a jamais versé dans un macronisme
profond donc euh donc euh que les que
ces deux personnes se réunissent et
parlent d'un d'un d'un seul d'un d'une
seule voix pour appeler à une
manifestation nationale c'est du d'union
national malheureusement pour des
raisons politiques
euh tous les partis ne n'ont pas voulu
alors que les partis n'étaient pas
conviés puisque c'était un appel aux
Français de venir manifester contre
l'antisémitisme en tout cas ils sont là
c'est ce que rappelle le le live text du
Figaro qui est en dessous de ce en
dessous de ce player si vous êtes sur le
site du du Figaro euh une si vous n'y
êtes pas si vous êtes sur la page
Youtube je vous donne l'info une partie
de la gauche donc qui est présente dans
la marche c'est ce que nous rappellent
nos correspondants sur place nous avons
été toujours dans les marches contre
l'antisémitisme a rappelé marine
Tondelier au côté de Fabien Roussel et
Olivier fort il était donc logique que
nous soyons là même nous sommes si nous
sommes troublés par la présence du RN
c'est hallucinant d'avoir marché avec
eux mais ce n'était pas à nous de sortir
de cette marche alors ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'on va peut-être
reprendre l'exégèse marine Tondelier
nous avons toujours été dans les marches
contre l'antisémitisme je vous cite
marine Tondelier parce que il y a quand
même une polémique on va revenir sur la
France insoumise mais même chez les
vers le mot qui revient en boucle depuis
le début de la scène c'est le mot
ambiguïé et le parti écologiste sur ces
questionsl n'y échappe pas dites-moi si
je me trompe mais il me semble à un
moment même que le patron des veres
n'était plus invité au dîner du chrish
oui oui les les les vers ont n'ont pas
toujours été aussi clairire que
qu'aujourd'hui dans dans cette dans
cette lutte non pas contre
l'antisémitisme mais contre une certaine
forme de de de d'islamoguchisme
d'islamowokisme et et tout ce qui touche
à Israël en
général ils onts étaient un peu parfois
parfois un peu particuliers donc
effectivement ils nont à plusieurs
reprises n'ont pas été invités au dîner
du CRIF je vous laisse on va peut-être
mettre en d'ailleurs en plein écran
cette image du début de de la
manifestation avec le
slogan qui est le mot d'ordre pour la
République contre
l'antisémitisme on peut peut-être
décrire ce que donner les noms de ce que
on voit on VO
àoite
que et on voit et tout à gauche cor de
Nan Monseig roug et puis de anciens
présidents de Françis Hollande quasiment
côte à côte je CIS y derrière il
y priv côte cô pour le
coupancien Premier
ministre avez vous avez une bon le maire
vous avez plus de 30 ministres qui sont
représentés à cette manifestation donc
dont la première ministre donc c'est il
y a une il y a une forte mobilisation de
l'exécutif pour cette
marche et je le rappelle est quand même
comme pour la République est contre
l'antisémitisme
euh Nicolas Sarko d'ailleurs c'est de
nouveau exprimé ce midi justifiant sa
présence et également celle du du du R
un des phénomènes mais puisquon a vu des
on voit quand même quelques ministres il
y a 33 ministres qui ont été annoncés
dans soit ici à Paris soit dans
d'autres villes de France quel est
l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement de cette
présenceenje l'enjeu c'est toujours le
même c'est celui de l'Union nationale
contre contre une thématique un sujet
qui touche l'ensemble de la nation ça
c'est discours officiel officiel après
je je je je crois je crois pour le coup
il y a une sincérité dans cet engagement
là donc même s'il y a des des positions
qui sont parfois parfois ambigu qui qui
peuvent revenir notamment sur le soutien
de d'Emmanuel Macron ou pas à une
solution à deux états une solution le
sur le sur le le soutien Israël puis
ensuite revenir la demande de celfu qui
fait qui fait énormément jaser en Israël
qui qui na
pas benamin Natan Premier ministre
israélien a répondu assez assez
vertement à à Emmanuel Macron hier quand
il a entendu C interview à la BBC donc
mais d'une manière générale le le
l'enjeu pour l'exécutif français est de
montrer que l'ensemble de la nation et
en tous les cas l'ensemble de l'exécutif
et derrière les français et notamment
les Français juifs on va si vous le
voulez bien de alors que la la
manifestation est en train de de
commencer essayer de de rejoindre
Vincent
roseron qui lui est sur place Vincent on
a vu le cortège commencer à à partir
est-ce qu'il y a du monde là où vous
êtes et bien oui il y a du monde parce
que comme vous l'avez vu le réseau ne
passe pas donc c'est vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est souvent une signe
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde et c'est le
cas alors je sais pas si vous pouvez
bien le voir moi je pas trop me
rapprocher parce qu'effectivement sinon
on perd la connexion tellement il y a de
gens sur la place mais l'esplanade des
Invalides est en train de se remplir
énormément beaucoup de gens comme vous
voyez sur ces images des gens continuent
d'affluer via l'arrière de cette place
des Invalides pour venir petit à petit
pour rejoindre cette esplanade avec
cette manifestation qui vient de partir
vous l'avez
dit merci beaucoup Vincent pour ces pour
ces premières précisions donc du monde
qui continue d'affluer c'est l'un des
enjeux hein de cette mobilisation Albert
c'est l'enje majeur c'est c'est le
nombre combien 20000 on parlait de 20000
l'idée c'était d'arriver à 100000 je
crois que les orordinateurs voulaient
100000 on se rappelle que après après le
l'affaire de
Carpentra le corps
[Musique]
d'un avec la
tombe 200000 personnes dans les rues
donc je sais pas si on on l'atteindra
mais en tous les cas il faut qu'il y ait
une masse critique pour montrer que
derrière derrière ce combat contre
l'antisémitisme il y a beaucoup de monde
est-ce que il y a pas quand même on
parle de de manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme mais est-ce que derrière
ces ces appellations qui sont les mêmes
il y a pas quand même deux réalités
différentes 1990 c'est
Carpentra c'est un antisémitisme on en
parlait tout à l'heure qu'on pense venir
de l'extrême droite une
résurgence des de l'occupation des
années noires aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est le même d'tisémitisme concr non
bien entendu c'est c'est plus tout à
fait le même antisémitisme même s'il y a
toujours un antisémitisme résiduel venu
de l'extrême droite mais comme son nom
l'indique il est résiduel donc
aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle F une
nouvelle phase de l'antisémitisme plutôt
d'extrême gauche plutôt venu de certains
quartiers qui qui avec avec
l'importation d'un d'un conflit entre
entre Israël Hamas et et donc et qui
génère on le voit aujourd'hui dans les
dans les actes an alors tous ne sont pas
issus de de de de cet extrême gauche là
mais les actes antisémites ont changé
l'antisémitisme a changé de nature alors
et dans les années 90 il était facile
enfin en tous les cas plus facile de
mobiliser la France et notamment la
gauche sur sur ce combat contre
l'antisémitisme parce que ça faisait
appel aux heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire et donc un combat contre
le fascisme qui revient donc là-dessus
il y avait il y avait les réponses
étaient était était courante et était
plus plus facile aujourd'hui C cet
anciinisme ayant changé de nature et ben
beaucoup de gens ne s'y retrouvent pas
tout à fait dans ce combat contre
l'antisimmitisme alors précisément et ça
beaucoup de gens vous parlez de la
gauche est-ce que la gauche justement
est encore plus divisé ce dimanche
malgré le défilé unitaire PS vert on le
voit aujourd'hui la nuupes c'est c'est
c'est un peu encore encore un peu plus
éclaté puisque les les filles n'ont pas
voulu participer à cette manifestation
lu faisant revêtir un caractère qu'elle
n'a pas qui était un soutien
inconditionnel Israël c'est ce que
reproche encore mélanchant aujourd'hui
au au à à cette manifestation sûr c'est
pas un soutien inconditionnel mais non
c'est pas un soutien inconditionnel
c'est est-ce qu'il y a il n'y a pas de
drapeau israélien il n'y a pas de
drapeau il y a pas d'appel la victoire
d'Israël il y a pas il y a juste un
appel qui était juste avant vous qui va
cette manifestation disait combien il
était critique à l'écart de l'ou on peut
être on peut être on peut être tout à
fait critique vis-à-vis d'Israël
juger que les les les positions de
certains ne sont pas bonnes sont que que
la démarche suivie n'est pas la bonne ça
c'est ça chacun réagit comme il veut
mais en tous les cas il y a une chose
est certaine c'est que la la
l'antimmitisme n'a pas sa lieu n'a pas
de n'a pas de lieu en n'a pas de raison
de de continuer à exister en France
question de mémoire peut-être que vous
avez pas la réponse comme ça exacte mais
est-ce que ça vous semble juste Jun smja
disait à l'instant mais finalement quand
on regarde les sondages d'opinion c'est
dans l'électorat RN qu'il a plus
antisémitisme que dans l'
de gauche radicale vrai faux je crois
avoir vu passer un sondage
ou de 2022 oùù on retrouvait
des une une proportion à peu près
équivalente aussi bien dans l'élector
dans l'électorat dans l'électorat RN
issu du RN sympathisant RN et dans
l'électorat d'extrême gauche vers autour
de 30 % là où de mémoire je je veux pas
meavancer autour de 30 % alors que dans
la moyenne nationale il est quelques
points en dessous est-ce que euh ça veut
dire que quand même il y a il y a dans
certaines tendances de l'opinion il y a
quand même une personne sur trois qui se
retrouve dans une forme
d'antisémitisme une personne sur quatre
ou sur C une personne sur 4 sur 5 donc
oui il y a toujours un fond il y a il y
a toujours un fond d'antisémitisme qui
existe qui perdure depuis depuis pas mal
de temps donc euh qui va qui va de des
des préjugés des préjugés classiques des
clichés à à une à une forme beaucoup
plus radical
est Albert euh on a vu ce matin
des mobilisation en tous les cas une
action de la France insoumise qui visait
à rendre hommage aux victimes du valdive
Manifeste hommage qui a été
perturbé par certains militants qui ont
contesté en tout cas qui ont protesté
contre je cite l'utilisation faite de la
mémoire c'était en tout cas ce que
disaient ces ces militants là est-ce que
que cette manifestation est-ce que cette
mobilisation là actuelle qu'on voit
divise encore plus la France insoumise
et divise encore plus en électorat alors
l'électorat je le crois je pense qu'il y
a une partie de l'électorat de la France
à soumise qui qui ne comprend pas les
les les ambiguïés des des élus et
notamment de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour ce
qui est maintenant des représentants de
la France insoumise il y a il y a un
corps qui fait bloc autour autour de ses
positions ce celle de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais de David gu aussi qui a
quand même sorti des énormités dans
sonant sa conférence à Tunis vendredi
soir c'est Israël les femmes éventré
c'est Israël Sabra Chatila c'est Isra
donc tout ce qui est faux SAB chatil le
commanditaire
çaens mais pour pour le reste
effectivement manuel B déclaré tout à
l'heure qu' ne voyait pas pourquoi il
faudrait sanctionner David Gueron mais
il ne voit la France insouise ne voit
jamais pourquoi on devrait les
sanctionner donc il et à l'inverse quand
il s'agit de Raquet garido qui aimet des
doutes sur sur le leadership de Jean-Luc
mélenchot elle elle est sanctionnée ça
c'est sûr et certain Rico nous dit
pourquoi ils n'ont pas mis Zemmour
devant c'est le seul dirigeant de parti
politique de confession juive en tout
cas non il y a je crois il y a le bon
bon pivé notamment et il y
a le père d'Élisabeth borne a été
déporté et pu pu et puis ça ne concerne
pas ça ne concerne pas les Juifs enfin y
a pas de raison de mettre en avant plus
les Juifs que les autres au contraire il
faut que l'ensemour est présent je crois
cette manifestation ou oui est
présent interv dans les manifestation
l'autre l'autre enjeu c'est la présence
du du RN c'est une première et une
première avec les propos dans le Figaro
de Serge clarfel
oui de Pierre Moscovici euh il y a 24
heures qui dit Marine Le Pen n'est pas
antisémite et ou encore Nicolas Sarkozi
dans les colonnes du du JDD qui va même
jusqu'à défendre le silence de
Jean-Marie Le Pen oui euh il y a ça a
fait polémique pour certains et pas chez
tous on voit bien au sein même de
l'exécutif puisque euh Olivier verrant
et le porte-parole du gouvernement est
très en pointe sur la lutte contre le le
le RN et notamment sa présence à les
manifestations alors que d'autres ne le
sont beaucoup moins et y compris dans la
majorité et et effectivement la la la la
présence du une ambivalence dans la
majorité sur ces questionsl oui parce
que tout il y a le B bon Pivet déjà
invité tout le monde même si elle a elle
elle a écarté l'idée de pouvoir défiler
en même temps que le RN et de ne voulant
pas être à côté dans tous les cas elle a
invité tout le monde il y a pas
d'exclusive et je trouve que dans C dans
cette dans cette dans ce lutte dans
cette lutte contre l'antisémitisme il
faut que l'ensemble de la population
l'ensemble le des Français soient
représentés qu'il viennent du RN qui
viennent de LFI qu'il viennent de
partout c'était pas une manifestation
c'est pas une manifestation politique
c'est pas une missation à l'initiative
de partis politique c'est c'est c'est
c'est ça qui que beaucoup de gens n'ont
pas compris d'ailleurs les sondages
montrent bien que les Français sont
plutôt d'accord avec l'idée même assez
d'accord avec l'idée que le RN soit
présent dans cette manifestation et y
compris chez chez les représentants chez
bon nombre de Français juifs qui ne voit
pas pourquoi les les rennes qui ont fait
leur m qui ont qui ont eu certes un
passé avec Jean-Marie Le Pen antisémite
qui a eu il y avait il y av un vrai
terro au départ mais Marine Le Pen elle
a a coupé les ponts avec avec avec ce
passé elle a même exclu son père en
grande partie pour ces raisonsl donc
elle elle a montré que elle elle pouvait
passer à autre chose et on peut lui en
savoir gr Yonathan Arfi qui le président
du CRIF sera présent ici demain en lui
posant la question mais de quelle
tendance est le
CRIF ça je ne sais pas je sais pas je
sais pas c'est euh je crois qu'il il ne
cherche pas à être vraiment avoir un
positionnement un positionnement
politique
euh parfois c un pe compréhensible
pourquoi elle est elle est refusé que le
le RN participe
bon on aurait pu on aurait pu le
comprendre il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui il on voit pas bien pourquoi
le le Ren participerait pas d'ailleurs
Marine Le Pen a dit une chose
elle nous sommes nous sommes là où nous
vons devons être tout à l'heure il y a
quelques minutes quand elle a été
interroger sur sa présence
elle elle veut lutter elle aussi contre
l'antisémitisme tant mieux tant mieux
que des des gens qui viennent d'un
d'un de la droite parfois de la droite
plus radicale ou de la gauche et
peut-être de la gauche plus radicale
lutte contre l'antisémitisme et contre
tous les racismes c'est aussi bien c'est
la 5ème grande manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme qu'est-ce qui vous
frappe dans celle-là moi ce qui me
frappe c'est c'est c'est c'est le manque
d'unité et c'est et c'est et c'est le
fait que elle a été polluée elle a été
polluée par ses polémiques politiques et
je trouve ça très très dommage j'ai
trouvé que l'initiative j'ai toujours
pensé que l'initiative de de de yelbon
privé de Gérard lâché d'avoir lancé
cette manifestation dans les colonne du
fiaro d'ailleurs était une très très
bonne
chose qui allait donner une assise
populaire nationale à cette à cette
lutte importante et le fait que des
petites polémiques politiques ce soit
grevé
là-dessus je trouve ça déplorable je
trouve ça déplorable c'est dommage pour
la la cause qui est une grande et belle
cause Jean-Louis Debray l'ancien
ministre de l'Intérieur que l'on voit
actuellement derrière président ancien
président bien évidemment de l'Assemblée
nationale
derrière y Bron PIV représentant
également de la communauté juives qui
sont bien évidemment en première
ligne les anciens présidents également
sont sont présents va peut-être voir
dans un instant Édouard Philippe et
Laurent fabus président du Conseil
constitutionnel on voit donc Nicolas
Sarkozi et François Hollande quel est
l'enjeu pour les anciens présidents dans
sa présence là là c'est je pense que
leur enjeu c'est de montrer l'unité il y
a un ancien président de droite un
ancien président de gauche qui montre
que queles que soient les sensibilités
politiques quels que soient les
les
passés on est au au contact des Français
qui veulent dire non à l'antisémitisme
15h30 bientôt sur le site du Figaro la
manifestation pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme vous le voyez est partie
à Paris avec en tête une bande rôle et
derrière y Bron pivé Gérard Larcher qui
sont les organisateurs en tous les cas
ceux qui ont lancé l'appel à cette
manifestation entouré de la première
ministre ellisabeth borne des
représentant de la communauté juive du
Grand Rabin a corcia et également des
deux anciens présidents de la République
on va essayer de retrouver Vincent
roseron sur place merci beaucoup Albert
Zenou d'être venu sur le plateau du
Figaro on vous laisse rattraper la
conférence de rédaction qui va s'ouvrir
et pour justement lire qu'est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir lire justement dans le dans
le figarou à partir de de ce soir et
dans les pages
politiques pas mal de choses les
contte-rendus des manifestations bien
entendu mais également des analyses sur
la position de d'Emmanuel Macron sur la
la
gauche le jeu de de LFI qui fait bande à
part et et pas mal de choses autour de
toute cette mobilisation merci beaucoup
Albert on va continuer à suivre ça avec
vous et on va continuer à suivre ça avec
les internautes du Figaro on va essayer
de retrouver alors que on voit la
ministre amieoua Castera ministre des
Sports on déploré justement le le grand
silence des milieux sportifs ces
dernières heures c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure manuel Vals aussi
l'ancien Premier ministre présent à
cette manifestation à Paris on va
essayer de retrouver Vincent roseron sur
place
Vincent quel est le est-ce que le monde
continue d'affluer là où vous êtes
puisque vous nous le disiez tout à
l'heure il y avait énormément de monde
qui continuaiit d'arriver là ça a l'air
un petit peu plus clair Semet derrière
vous alors c'est clair parce que je me
trouve complètement à l'arrière de cette
manifestation puisque je depuis tout à
l'heure à l'avant il n'y a vraiment pas
beaucoup de de réseau mais si vous
regardez sur les côtés donc là en fait
c'est le départ de la manif qui est en
face de moi au niveau du pont les les
manifestants tournent à droite pour
commencer cette manifation mais ici vous
voyez que il y a des des des des des
gens qui continuent d'arriver par ce par
ce passage euh par par le métro qui est
ouvert encore par là-bas donc donc des
gens arrivent par ici ils arrivent aussi
de l'autre côté donc même maintenant
donc 20 minutes après une demi-heure
pardon après le début officiel de la
manifestation qui comme d'ab comme
d'habitude est parti un peu plus tard
les les gens continuent d'arriver petit
à petit sur la place l'esplalade des
Invalides merci beaucoup Vincent on va
essayer de de retrouver de voir
également les les images qui sont à la
tête maintenant de ce cortage les les
images tournées par nos confrères de la
FP pendant qu'on vous laisse Vincent euh
interroger bien des personnes qui
viennent à cette manifestation voir
pourquoi elles viennent quel est le
l'enjeu pour elles qu'est-ce qu'elles
attendent est-ce qu'elles sont encore
elles ont ce sentiment de solitude ce
sentiment d'isolement dont nous parlait
à l'instant Albert Zenou ou encore avant
lui Gil Smadja on va vous proposer de
suivre également euh ces ces images de
les vivre de vivre cette manifestation
de vivre cette mobilisation mobilisation
également on le disait en région
puisqu'il y a euh également 70
rassemblements qui sont lancés qui sont
organisés 3000 personnes à Lyon 3000
personnes à Strasbourg manifestation à
Nice ou encore à Marseille tout à
l'heure où on a vu un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont manifesté qui sont
qui se sont mobilisé et qui sont
présentes pour des manifestants cette
marche est transpartisane et elle doit
rassembler tout le monde c'est ce que
déclare euh un certain nombre de de
personnes qui ont été croisées par les
euh journalistes du du Figaro qui sont
sur place témoignage notamment d'Ismaël
et Yasmine qui sont tous les deux
fonctionnaires aucun des deux né juif
Ismaël lui est musulman nous dit notre
correspondant il est important dun d'ux
d'être présent car c'est une marche
transpartisane qui doit rassembler tout
le monde ce qui se passe pour les Juifs
est inacceptable euh on l' et et on voit
également donc un certain nombre de de
pancartes nous marchons contre
l'antisémitisme al c'était une pancarte
de renaissance mais on leur a dit qu'on
avait leur avait donné nous sommes
exactement là où nous devons être c'est
ce que vient de déclarer c'est ce qu'a
déclaré plus exactement Marine Le Pen au
début de cette
manifestation est arrivée devant les
Invalides tout à l'heure où elle
était entouré d'un d'une forêt de
caméras de députés et de de de du groupe
qu'elle dirige à l'Assemblée nationale
et également de partisans quelques échop
Fouré ont été observés après le départ
de la marche devant l'hôtel des
Invalides un groupe d'une quarantaine de
personnes a tenté de faire barrage à
l'avancée du RN c'est peut-être ce qui
explique pourquoi on a vu un petit peu
ce cette tension ce ce ce bazar autour
de l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen avec des
membres d'un collectif qui s'appelle le
collectif golem qui dit nous on décage
nous on décage l'extrême droite vous
savez également qu'il y a eu des
incidents ce matin également aux abords
de l'ancien emplacement du du valdive
hein autour de de birakim euh dans le
15e arrondissement où la France
insoumise avait organisé un hommage euh
aux victimes du veldive et un certain
nombre de personnes euh ont protesté
contre cette présence et contre ce qu'il
considérait être une instrumentalisation
de la part d'une partie de la part de la
France à insoumise on l'a dit toi tout à
l'heure une partie de la gauche est elle
aussi présente on voit également on a vu
également Fabien Roussel marine
Tondelier et Olivier fort défilé côte à
côte et puis également la présence
d'Éric cioti qui lui regrette une
absence celle d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
une faute ce sera une faute devant
l'histoire dans ces moment le chef de
l'État doit être là pour l'unité de la
nation juge le président des
républicains c'est son absence qu' remet
aujourd'hui dangereusement en question
ce qui est intéressant c'était ce que
disait tout à l'heure ce que disait à
l'instant Albert Zenou il y a eu une
hésitation de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a déclaré devant les descendants de
la famille du capitaine drefus hier lors
d'un d'une rencontre que sa présence
pouvait remettre en cause l'unité
nationale et c'était en tous les cas ce
qui était ce qui était
invoqué autre déclaration celle bien
entendu d'un des d'un des maîtres
d'œuvre de cette en tous les cas d'un
des deux initiateurs de cette marche le
président du Sénat deuxème personnage de
l'État Gérard Larché notre ordre du jour
c'est la République Gérard Larché qui
avait lancé cette semaine dans les
colonnes du Figaro au côté de Yael brun
pivé la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale cet appel a marché aujourd'hui
et on voit justement les deux euh
responsable marcher côte à côte entre
les deux anciens présidents à droite sur
l'image François Hollande et à gauche
Nicolas Sarkozi ça c'est quand on les
regarde de face un engagement de bonne
foi de la part du RN selon Nicolas
Sarkozi c'est ce qu'a déclaré en tout
cas l'ancien président dans les colonnes
de nos confrères du du Journal du
Dimanche à qui ilacorde un long
interview est si difficile de faire une
pause devant le sujet qui doit nous
réunir
le chef du la chef du rassemblement
national à l'assemblée a affirmé qu'il
ne peut exister en matière
d'antisémitisme aucune ambigué reconnaî
en et fait valoir l'ancien président de
la République Marine Le Pen qui
également s'est défendu d'être et et a
défendu sa présence et ici cet
après-midi entre l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat ù d'où est parti la marche
auparavant ant Alain finkelcot s'en est
pris d'une nouvelle fois à la France
insoumise qu'elle qu'il accuse d'être un
parti
antisémite je cite il faut mettre ses
montres à l'heure a dit le déclaré le
philosophe il y a un parti antisémite
aujourd'hui en France c'est la France
insomisme c'est David guireud qui s'est
illustré tout récemment Louis Boyard
Daniel auonau Mathilde Panau les voilà
les antisémite d'aujourd'hui sous la
direction éclairée de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est en tout cas ce qu'estime Alain
Finel CR chez nos confrères d'LCI le
live text continue de vous donner des
des informations sur le le site du
Figaro j'en profite pour vous signaler
et ça vous pouvez le voir d'ailleurs si
vous voyez le live text du Figaro qu'il
y a une mobilisation à Nice on a vu
également du monde qui est en train
d'arriver encore ici sur l'explanade des
Invalides où on va essayer de
retrouver Vincent roseron euh
effectivement encore encore encore
encore beaucoup de monde he qui arrive
Vincent
oui effectivement je sais pas si vous
recevez toujours mes images maisess de
me rapprocher pour que vous voyez ce
monde sur la place des Invalides vous le
voyez sur ces images la place qui se qui
est qui se remplit alors que la
manifestation est partie les gens
progresse petit à petit maintenant
a
citoyens des personnalités aussi qui
sont pressents aujourd'hui et qui
commencent à
marcher Vincent il y a une chose qui est
assez frappante quand on regarde en tout
cas la tête du cortège c'est que il n'y
a pas de slogans qui sont lancés est-ce
que ça correspond à un mot d'ordre de
cette
manifestation alors je sais pas si ça
correspond à un mot d'ordre mais
effectivement c'est une manifestation
dans le calme il n'y aura pas de prise
de parole il a eu quelques quelques
champs quelques champs quelques
quelques quelques slogans qui ont quand
même été é été lancé non non non à
l'antisémitisme qu'on a entendu au début
de de avant que la manifestation ne
parte on a aussi entendu au moment où
Marine
Tondelier Olivier fort et et et Fabien
Roussel sont arrivés ils ont été un peu
hués de la part de de certaines
personnes d'autres personnes qui étaient
à côté de moi ont regretté justement que
il y ait ce genre de de de polémique à
ce moment il trouvait que ce n'était pas
ce n'était pas le le bon moment pour
pour faire
ça pas beaucoup de jeunes nous dit cet
internaute d'autres internautes nous
disent que les plans sont serrés qu'il y
a pas de vue aérienne qu'il y a personne
ça veut dire qu'il y a personne dans les
ruees vous vous avez j'ai l'impression
quand même plutôt qu'on qu'on constate
l'inverse quand on voit vos images et
quand on voit surtout que les images
sont serrées ce qui est le signe qu'il y
a quand même beaucoup de
monde alors Vincent je pense que vous
n'avez pas entendu la question mais il y
a un certain nombre d'internautes qui
nous disent que il y a pas tant de monde
que ça or quand on voit vos images et
que on voit certaines ça pour nous c'est
un signe qui est très fort c'est quand
on voit que les les images sont figées
c'estd qu'il y a toujours il y a du
monde en tout cas là où on se trouve
alors est-ce que il y a est-ce que les
ruses sont si vitees que ça que le
disent certains internautes ou bien
est-ce que vraiment vous constater une
affluence alors l'ESP des Invalides est
une immense place avec beaucoup d'espace
vert d'où les gens ne se mettent pas
forcément dessus c'est pour pour ça que
ça on a l'impression que c'est un peu
vide mais je peux vous assurer que elle
est quand même assez remplie en tout cas
la route est assez remplie beaucoup de
gens sont présents en ce moment sur les
plananade des Invalides beaucoup de
personnes moi je je forc on s'attendait
pas forcément avoir autant de personnes
je pense que c'était ce qui était
attendu forcément par les gens qui ont
qui ont organisé cette manifestation
mais
aujourd'hui il y a effectivement pas mal
de personnes et si vous voyez sur ces
images là que je suis en train de vous
montrer euh c'est un cortège assez
compact qui s'avance euh vers la fin de
l'espade des
invalidestivement un esplan un cortège
qui est assez fourni et qui peut
contenir plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes hein sur les l'esplenade
des Invalides et qui fait route vers
effectivement le l'Assemblée nationale
et euh les boulevards qui euh font qui
relient euh l'Assemblée nationale euh au
Sénat le trajet qui était annoncé vous
allez me dire si je me trompe d'ailleurs
Vincent mais il me semble que c'était le
boulevard Saint-Germain et le boulevard
Saint-Michel avant une arrivé prévue une
arrivée prévue aux alentours de 19h
autour de euh autour de la place Edmond
Rostan près euh du Sénat on voit
quelques drapeau israélien euh
ilgalement quelques drapeaux euh
tricolore et visiblement pas mal d'élus
là où vous
êtes alors j'ai pas forcément entendu
votre votre question parce que comme
d'habitude ça coupe pas mal mais vous
voyez que là je suis au niveau des des
élu du rassemblement national vous voyez
sur cette image Jordane bardellaa Marine
Le Pen Sébastien Chenu qui sont présents
et qui sont en fait complètement à
l'arrière de ce de de ce cortège comme
le disaient plusieurs manifestants de N
pas une volonté effectivement de se
mélanger au reste des des manifestants
alors Vincent tout à l'heure c'est ce
que nous signalait le live text du
Figaro certains ont pris à parti
justement ces ces élus et ces
représentants ces militants du du
rassemblement national est-ce que vous
avez vu c'est est-ce que vous avez
assisté à ces scènes alors que là on
voit plutôt des des des personnes
applaudir
alors effectivement là allez-y les gens
qui app j'ai pas entendu la première
partie de votre question en fait parce
que Marine la était en train de
s'exprimer et des gens on l'ont l'ont
applaudi c'est ce qu'on VI
d'entendre effectivement la question
c'était ce qui s'était passé avant
apparemment c'est ce que disait le live
text du Figaro
des personnes s'en sont pris à la
présence des élus du remblement national
est-ce que vous avez assisté à la scène
c'était juste ma ma question alors qu'on
voit effectivement qu'il y a là aussi
encore un peu de monde parce que les
images
figent alors je me recule pour que vous
voyez les
images alors que le cor semble faire
arrêt en en tête de manifestation
en tête de manifestation vous le
voyez je partage vos
comment vos
commentaires des drapeau israéliens dans
la
rueelle est dans ce sens elle à
droiteè pas un mot sur l'attaque d'hier
à Lyon d'identitaire contre une
conférence sur la Palestine nous dit
Morgan écoute effectivement on va
regarder ce dont il
s'agit
alors il y a encore effectivement un
certain nombre de gens qui nous disent
il y a pas beaucoup de monde apparemment
en tous les cas c'est plutôt l'inverse
qui nous est donné alors il y a des
objectifs de chiffres qui n'ont pas été
donnés explicitement mais enfin en tous
les cas qui sont visés c'est ce que nous
disait tout à l'heure Albert Zenou he on
aimerait bien avoir alentours de 100000
personnes c'est en tout cas ce que
souhaite ce que souhaiteraient certains
organisateurs pour l'instant on n' pas
encore d'estimation il faut attendre la
la fin de
l'après-midi pour euh avoir cette ses
estimations le cortège continue donc sa
route sur le belle boulevard
Saint-Germain euh Momo nous dit il y a
moins de drapeaux français dans les
manifestations proalestiniennes et une
scène qui a été assez étonnante
d'ailleurs qui a été montré à New York
ces dernières heures où on voit une
manifestation effectivement en faveur de
la cause palestinienne avec des drapeaux
américains qui sont arrachés et des
drapeaux palestiniens qui sont mis à la
la place et ça a visiblement beaucoup
frappé euh en tous les cas sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont partagé euh
cette cette scène euh flight 92 nous dit
qu'il est content de ce sursaut
républicain et bien vous aussi est-ce
que vous partagez cette satisfaction
alors que vous voyez encore le monde qui
continue d'affluer ici euh à sur
l'esplanade des Invalides derrière
C manifestants qui étaient rassemblés il
se trouve également le le C du
rassemblement national avec Marine Le
Pen qui était en tête entourée d'un
certain nombre de députés du mouvement
manifestation vous le voyez si vous
regardez également le live Tex du Figaro
à Nice
également à Strasbourg à Lyon le un
lourd dispositif nous signaletons
également de sécurité a été déployé pour
encadrer et sécuriser la manifest
station à 3000 personnes 3000 membres
des forces de l'ordre ont été déployé
c'est ce qu'annoncé Gérald armanin en
fin de sommeil en fin de semaine
euh le cortège rappelle-t-on est composé
d'un grand nombre
d'élus et qui avance sous haute
protection euh le live Tex donc comme on
peut le voir sur une photo de notre
conur Célestine gentillum je rappelle
également que vous pouvez nous suivre
sur la page Youtube du du Figaro vous
êtes euh vous êtes nombreux et également
sur le le sur le site du Figaro si vous
voulez partager des commentaires c'est
sur cette page qui sont actuellement
ouverts vous êtes les les bienvenus pour
nous nous suivre et pour poser vos
questions partager vos remarques dans la
limite bien évidemment et dans le cadre
plus exactement puisqu'il y a pas de
limite de la Charte Marie nidelgo qui
est revenu DEP Polynésie visiblement euh
qui se trouve également dans le dans le
dans le en tête de cortège et dit marine
mais c'est Anne Idalgo bien évidemment
en train de discuter avec l'ancien
président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozi et qui est accompagné de son
épouse Carla Bruni et derrière eux
l'ancien Premier ministre Jean-Marc et
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Jean-Marc héros lesdita religieux
leurabahim Corscia et Monseigneur
Mathieu rouget évec de nanter qui sont
écal présent au côté de Clément bonne le
ministre des Transports vous les voyez
également en ce moment vous continuer de
partager vos commentaires je vais en
prendre quelques-uns essayer de répondre
à vos questions si j'ai la la réponse on
va peut-être poser la
question cette question d'un internut
qui nous dit c'est pas la première fois
qu'il nous le dit il y a très peu de
jeunes vcent reeron si vous m'entendez
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer il y a
très peu de
jeunes
est-ce qu'il y a des jeunes à la
manifestation alors je sais pas si vous
vous m'entendez moi je vous entends
alors moi je sais pas si vous vous
m'entendez mais moi je vous entends en
tout cas et bien effectivement il y a
pas énormément de jeunes à cette
manifestation le public qui est qui est
ici est plutôt est plutôt plus âgé que
d'autres manifestations qu'il a eu en
France ces derniers temps je pense par
exemple à la manifestation contre les
retraites là il y a effectivement
beaucoup plus de de personnes âgées que
de jeunes qui sont présents aujourd'hui
à cette manifestation ça veut pas dire
qu'il y en a aucun il y en a il y a des
familles qui sont venus ensemble des des
mères de famille qui qui ont venu qui
sont venus amener leur leur fils et
leurs filles j'entendais d'ailleurs je
discutais tout à l'heure avec l'E d'elle
qui me disait que pour elle c'est très
très important d'emmener ses enfants ici
puisque c'est un événement qui est très
important pour elle et pour la France se
disait-elle et donc il était pour elle
primordial que c'est que ces enfants
soit présent aujourd'hui à cette
manifestation et bien effectivement si
ces personnes sont prêtes à vous
répondre on sera très heureuse de les de
les prendre en direct merci beaucoup
pour cette pour ces premières précisions
beaucoup de Français juifs chez eux ici
sont contre ces frappes de tsal sur des
civiles et des hôpitaux à Gaza nous dit
Christian Léon effectivement c'est une
question que pose Christian Léon mais
qui a été abordée et auquel ont répondu
clairement Gill Smadja tout à l'heure et
Albert zénou il y a effectivement un
certain nombre de gens qui manifestent
aujourd'hui mais qui n'approuvent pas
forcément soit l'opération en cours sur
la façon dont elle est menée en tous les
cas par Israël et ou encore le
gouvernement israélien de de Benjamin
netanahou euh donc effectivement cette
question a
été abord et la la la la la marche
d'aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est ce que
font valoir ces organisateur et c'est ce
que nous rappelit tout à l'heure nos nos
intervenants est une marche contre
l'antisémitisme ce qui est intéressant
également c'est de voir
euh que
souvent les Juifs de France sont en tous
les cas c'est ce que dénoncent les
organisateurs de cette marche les
victimes euh de de ce conflit qui se
passe au Proche Orient et euh et qui
sont pris pour cible alors que ce sont
des des ressortissants euh français
euh Paul nous dit ils ont voulu en faire
un coup politique malheureusement c'est
l'antisémitisme qui en profite ça on
demandera euh posera la question tout à
l'heure à Véronique rissou parce que
plus pour pour l'instant c'est c'est
plutôt les
euh son les sondages notamment le
sondage odoxa BB bogbon consulting pour
Le Figaro publié dans les pages du
Figaro ce vendredi ont montré l'inverse
en tous les cas un fort soutien de
l'opinion euh entre re 69 % pour notre
sondage 71 % son un sondage fait par nos
confrères du JD aujourd'hui qui montre
un soutien à cette marche contre
l'antisémitisme
euh voilà nos dirigeants encore face à
l'échec les Juifs de France méritent
mieux on va encore faire culpabiliser
les Français nous dit Lily Morgan
pourquoi vous vous dites ça quel
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça ce
sera intéressant de
justement que vous précisiez Lili votre
votre point vue parce que pour l'instant
on voit est-ce que c'est l'échec de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme et vous
faites allusion au 1242 acte antisémite
recensé depuis le seul 7 octobre ou bien
est-ce que ce serait un éventuel écheec
de la marche pour l'instant rien nous
permet de dire que c'est un échec plutôt
les images que nous voyons montrent
plutôt l'inverse
euh et
euh chardon dénonce une jeunesse
conditionné depuis l'enfance par la
gauche éducative en tous les cas il y a
encore ici quelques jeunes qui sont sur
place l'affluence justement on y revient
avec vous Vincent et j'ai une question
supplémentaire quel est le le dispositif
de sécurité autour de
vous alors le dispositif de sécurité
autour de moi il est assez euh pour pas
dire léger en fait on ne le voit pas
forcément mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
toutes les entrées vous le voyez là je
suis au niveau de la du centre de la
place des Invalides toutes les entrées
sont sécurisées avec des fouilles de la
part des des CRS vous voyez peut-être
les camions qui sont loin et bien c'est
le cas à chaque euh à chaque entrée de
de de de cette place là une fois que
nous sommes sur les Invalides bien sûr
il y a des forces de sécurité qui sont
présentes on en a vu des des policiers
des gendarmes qui sont présent sur cette
esplanade mais on ne les voit pas
forcément
énormément enfin il ne se montre pas
forcément beaucoup mais ça a été très
sécurisé en amont en fait de cette
manifestation est-ce qu'il y a des
est-ce qu'il y a des fouille est-ce que
il y a
des des des policiers eux qui sont plus
déployé en Amond du cortège oui oui
oui
alors en amont du Corel je pourrais pas
pour répondre parce que je je me trouve
pas mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que oui il y a eu des fouilles
pour les gens qui qui qui arrivaient
alors moi je suis arrivé assez tôt sur
sur cette ESPAD des invalide et c'est
invalide effectivement quand on arrivait
en métro on était pas fouillé mais je
pense que depuis ça a changé le le le
métro invalide a fermé au début de cette
manifestation pour des raisons de
sécurité et du coup tous les gens qui
arrivé arrivé par d'autres stations donc
arrivé par d'autres artères et donc eux
étaient fouillés avant d'arriver on voit
on continue de voir un certain nombre de
gens arrivés merci Vincent pour ces
précisions je vais je vais vous laisser
essayer d'en d'en croiser d'en discuter
avec quelques un pour qu'ils viennent
justement témoigner à l'antenne nous
dire pourquoi il ils sont présents
contre quoi il manifeste s'il manifeste
bien pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui quels sont
leurs sentiments est-ce qu'ils trouvent
qu'on en fait assez qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est les questions un
peu qu'on qu'on se pose pendant ce
temps-là alors que l'on voit le début du
cortège continuer d'avancer sur les
artères parisiennes en direction du
Sénat avec les les organisateurs et ceux
qui ont lancé l'initiative de cette
manifestation les anciens présidents de
la République la première ministre
ellisabeth born les représentants de la
communauté juive et les plus hauts
représentants de l'État dont les anciens
présidents je vous donne quelques
témoignages et quelques informations qui
viennent d'ailleurs en France plus de 70
rassemblements nous dit la FP ont été
annoncés dans toute la France 73 he très
exactement et notamment à Nice où il y a
eu près de 3000 personnes selon la la
police qui ont participé en fin de
matinée à un grand rassemblement donc
toujours avec ce mot d'ordre pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme
avec deux figures locales l'ancien maire
le maire al de la ville Christian
estroszi et de le responsable de
l'antenne locale du Conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
France dont on voit le président ici sur
ces images et qui sera présent dans les
studios du Figaro demain en fin
d'après-midi dans point de vue aux
alentours de 17h cette montée de
l'antisémitisme nous terrorise israélien
et Palestiniens ont le même ennemi le
Hamas selon carlon sban qui est une chef
d'entreprise niissoise dont la famille
envisage aujourd'hui de quitter la
France il y a un autre rassemblement à
l'appel des de l'Association des maires
de France qui était attendu dans
l'après-midi dans le vie niice du poteau
Association des Maires de France dirigé
par le maire de can David lissnard AR
ran plus de 700 personnes dans de
nombreux élus se sont réunis devant la
mairie selon la préfecture et on va je
vous donne juste avant de rejoindre
Vincent reoseron le témoignage du maire
Nicolas PS Nicolas meer rignol rival
d'Olivier fort quand l'antisémitisme
ressurgit c'est une menace pour la
République toute entière mais il y a une
menace plus grande encore c'est notre
silence et notre indifférence participer
à ce rassemblement est une obligation
morale et citoyenne pour toutes celles
et ceux qui refusent la haine de l'autre
c'est ce que déclare Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol un nos confrères de
lafp 500 personnes se sont rassemblé
devant l'hôtel de ville également de
Brest on va rejoindre Vincent reoseron
qui lui se trouve à
sur l'esplanade des Invalides et avec
des manifestants Vincent vous avez la
parole
oui effectivement oui effectivement je
me retrouve avec Sylvia et Marc qui sont
venus à cette manifestation aujourd'hui
alors première question toute simple
mais pourquoi être ici aujourd'hui
pourquoi c'éit important pour vous de
venir ici c'est une manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme on se sent très
concerné oui en tant que en tant que
juif on est particulièrement concerné
aussi en tant que citoyen français et
quêtre
humain alors ça fige encore une fois ce
qui prouve qu'il y a quand même du monde
et on espère avoir justement ces deux
manifestants qui qui était là et qui
nous disent combien c'est important pour
eux dans justement dans cette
manifestation contre contre
l'antisémitisme manifestation dans le
corortarge de tête vient encore une fois
de marquer un arrêt euh ici sur le qui
semble être le boulevard
Saint-Germain à Paris euh dès qu'on
retrouve Vincent roseron on on continue
de on écoutera la suite de leur de leur
témoignage l'antisémitisme la haine des
Juifs pouvant conduire au pire crime
contre l'humanité n'est pas un détail de
l'histoire c'est ce que a déclaré le
maire PS de Brest François cuyandre
devant une foule rassemblée sur la pluie
le détail de l'histoire c'est bien
entendu une allusion à cette phrase de
Jean-Marie Le Pen en
1987 quand il était interrogé sur les
camp de concentration cette haine
qu'elle soit dirigée contre nos
compatriotes de confession juive ou de
confession musulmane n'a aucune place
dans notre République il n'y a pas de
place pour l'ambigué face au poison de
la haine c'est ce qu'a déclaré donc le
le maire PS de Brest où 500 personnes
étaient réunis plusieurs milliers de
personnes en revanche se sont rassemblé
de l'autre côté à l'autre bout bout de
la France à Strasbourg dimanche matin et
là on a observé d'ailleurs la présence
de
plusieurs députés LFI qui étaient venus
de de Paris notamment François Ruffin ou
Alexis corbierre et plusieurs élus
insoumis comme Clémentine hatin ou
Raquel garidau qui ont répondu à l'appel
du député Lafi de Strasbourg c'est
intéressant parce que ce sont des euh
toute une partie des des des élus LFI et
de responsables LFI qui sont opposés en
interne à Jean-Luc Mélanchon dont bien
sûr Raquel garideau qui vient d'être mis
en retrait et interdit de parole à
l'Assemblée nationale enfin au sein du
groupe LFI pour 4
mois le député de la Somme François
Ruffin d'ailleurs a plaidé pour un
moment de dignité de gravité et de
demander au moins pendant 24 heures tout
d'arrêter toute polémique pas sûr qu'il
soit entendu plus de 3000 personnes
également à Lyon selon la préfecture se
sont rassemblés place Bellecour devant
la statue du Veilleur de pierre qui est
et le Mémorial de la Résistance
française à l'occupation nazie le maire
de la ville l'écologiste grégoryi douset
également pris la la parole ainsi que la
députée
Renaissance et le président du Crif
auvern ronalp Richard Zelmati qui a
dénoncé l'exploitation politique de
l'antisémitisme par je cite l'extrême
gauche et un effet d'obben saisi par une
extrême droite opportuniste a-t-il
déclaré un manifest un manifestant qui
avait é euh rencontré euh à préciser que
c'était important d'être là en tant que
personne qui refuse le racisme une foule
très nombreuse rassemblée à Paris contre
l'antisémitisme c'est en tous les cas
les premiers euh les premiers constats
qui sont faits par nos confrères de de
la
FP et euh pour s'en rendre compte et
bien on va retrouver sur place notre
envoyé spécial Vincent roseron qui est
également avec certains manifestants
Vincent vous avez la parole
oui effectivement on s'est perdu tout à
l'heure puisque comme vous le savez il y
a beaucoup de gens et le et le réseau
passe assez malvec syvia et Marc qui
sont qui sont partis en avant du coup de
la méitation pour avancer mais tous les
deux étaient d'accord pour une chose
pour me dire que pour eux c'était très
important en tant que juif il n'avait
pas forcément vécu d'acte antisémite
pour eux mais il manifestai en
solidarité et pour eux c'était très très
important d'être ici aujourd'hui i je me
trouve actuellement toujours au queue de
cortège puisque c'est l'endroit où on
capte le mieux pour pouvoir vous donner
des des informations et ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que pour l'instant je
suis à la fin du cortège à cette fin de
cortège justement il y a les députés du
rassemblement national et quand il
passent il y a souvent des gens qui
crient qui leur disent de ne pas de
partir de cette manifestation là ça a
été le cas il y a quelques instants
justement euh et et voilà c'est c'est
effectivement ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
entendu d'ici est ce que vous avez pu
constater précisément Vincent est-ce que
les députés du rassemblement national
reste là ou ont prévu de commencer à
défiler alors les les les députés du
rastional ont ont commencé à à défiler
vous avez vu sur mes image tout à
l'heure alors ont commencé ils ont pas
avancé énormément comme cette
manifestation forcément vous le savez
début de manifestation quand il y a
beaucoup de gens on démarre et on avance
petit à petit et là Marine Le Pen et
ainsi que les autres membres du
rassemblement nationale ont commencé à
marcher et ont effectué 300 m mais ils
sont encore toujours dans cette
manifestation malgré des gens qui
passent et qui se plaignent de leur
présence alors effectivement ce sera
aussi également intéressant d'avoir
votre leur point de vue si vous allez si
vous arrivez à les
savoirement entendre également les les
réponses qui peuvent apporter aux
question au questions qui se
pose on continue
les alors Vincent reoseron vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose il a la
parole je suis incapable de vous direz
rien aucune information alors oui c
c'était c'était juste pour vous dire
qu'effectivement il y a autour aussi
rassemble nationale beaucoup de beaucoup
de gens qui sont qui sont avec eux et
qui applaudissent le long de quand
Marine Le Pen avance donc voilà il y a
un peu ces C ces deux ambiances tout le
long des gens qui qui qui marchent lors
de cette manifestation et lors de ce
passage du cortège on va l'appeler comme
ça du rassemblement nationale qui se
trouve complètement en queue de de
cortège de cette marche contre
l'antisémitisme comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images je me trouve
complètement à la fin et c'est sur là où
vous voyez des drapeaux français un peu
plus loin c'est ici que se trouvent les
élus du rassemblement
national merci beaucoup et ben on
continue de de de d'avoir de prendre vos
vos informations et et bien sûr les
témoignages les paroles de manifestants
qui sont sur place alors que vient de
nous rejoindre quelqu'un qui qu'on
connaît bien ici au Figaro qu'on est
content de revoir George kusmanovic
merci beaucoup d'être là c'est
intéressant de vous avoir également
parce que vous avez été
conseiller de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
avant de connaître le sort qui est
apparemment celui de Raquel garido
aujourd'hui mais avant d'autres
personnes notamment François François
coq dans la mouvance duquel vous vous
trouviez à l'époque on va y revenir dans
un instant je donne quelques témoignages
également de de manifestants qui ont été
rencontrés par nos confrères de la FP je
ne pensais pas devoir manifester un jour
contre l'antisémitisme ce que déclare
Johanna qui qui est secrétaire qui a 46
ans qui est secrétaire médical en saints
venu pour la seule raison de ne pas
avoir peur d'être juif la France compte
donc la communauté juive la plus
importante d'Europe avec plus de 500000
personnes et on vous le disait tout à
l'heure 3000 personnes ont notamment
manifesté à Lyon autant à Nice et
également quelques milliers à Strasbourg
notre ordre du jour c'est la République
c'est ce qu'a déclaré Gérard Larcher
George kusmanovic bonjour donc merci
beaucoup d'être d'être là bonjour V
d'abord un premier constat sur cette
manifestation un premier g un premier
commentaire mais écoutez j'en viens
directement j'étais là au au premier
rassemblement à 13h donc ça grossi petit
petit et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que alors je connais pas encore les
chiffres mais ça commence bien
rempli des invalidesonde donc il y avait
du monde malgré la pluie parce que
jusqu'à 14h30 c'était cétait assez
mouillé euh et ce qui est intéressant
c'est dans ce gen ce genre de
rassemblement c'est de de voir qu'on
peut faire France
on croise des gens que qu'on n pas vu
depuis longtemps ou
d'autres qui qui qui vous saluent et ça
peut être des gens de gauche peut des
gens de droite mais qui se
réunissent par un souci d'unité
nationale sur une thématique qui nous
réunit tous qui sont cell de la valeur
des valeurs de la République et qui sont
parfaitement résumé dans le premier
article de notre
Constitution vous êtes la France
indivisible la France indivisible bien
évidemment et la République une est
indivisible le la question également qui
se pose c'est la présence du
rassemblement national est-ce que ça ça
vous
gêne j'ai communiqué dessus j'ai rappelé
comme certains le passé du rassemblement
national quand c'était le Front
National et que certains des cadres des
des responsables politiques de du
rassemblement national ont eu un passé
plus que douteux mais je suis comme
sergefeld je salue l'évolution en fait
c'est ça qui est positif dans ce
contexte- là c'est vous croyez à la
réalité de cette évolution mais je crois
la réalité de l'évolution de certains on
l'a bien vu avec certains certains
députés du rassemblement national je ne
crois pas pour certains autres encore
une fois qui qui ont quand même un passé
très très très chargé mais c'est positif
dans le contexte d'antisémitisme que
nous connaissons que une organisation
politique qui vient de l'antisémitisme
d'extrême droite très sévère euh et bien
Coré je tire et j'ai l'impression que
c'est ce que ressentent un certain
nombre de Français donc c'est y compris
S crfeld qui n'est pas n'importe qui
quand même dans la chasse au
nazi donc c'est c'est une chose positive
si elle est authentique al bien sûr j'ai
critiqué en rappelant le passé de
certains du rassemblement national quand
monsieur Jordan Bardella était incapable
de dire que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite il y a eu ce matin un
rassemblement de en tout les cas un H
image que voulait rendre un certain
nombre de députés de la France insemise
auprès du du valdive au valdiv et aux
victimes du du
valdive hommage qui a été perturbé par
un certain nombre de manifestation de
manifestants qui reprocha à ces
personnes je cite d'instrumentaliser la
la mémoire votre point de vue sur ce qui
s'est passé ce matin
mais mon point de vue c'est que la
France pardon oui la France insoumise a
essayé de se rattraper au Bran au
dernier moment en faisant ce dépôt de
gerbe alors que tout simplement ils
auraient pu être là à la manifestation
où se retrouvve des gens qui sont
évidemment pas d'accord sur le plan
politique donc c'est ce genre la marche
contre l'antisémitisme il pouvait
parfaitement y venir mais le ce qui est
terrible c'est les symboles que ça
renvoie et c'est voulu par la France
insoumise c'est que il il manifestent
qu'ils sont contre l'antisémitisme mais
contre l'antisémitisme d'avant celui
atroce qui a mené à la choie
celui de l'extrême droite qu'on a connu
en France en particulier les années 30
mais par contre ils sont aveugles à
l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui qui nous
vient de l'islam politique ça ils sont
totalement hermétiques voire on pourrait
dire pour certains d'entre eux comme
députés gurou qui sont qui sont siené
antisémite à la limite de
l'antisémitisme par les propos qu'il
tiennent et par le fait que au lieu de
calmer les choses car le personnel
politique en France aujourd'hui devrait
rappeler que nous ne sommes pas
israéliens nous sommes pas Palestiniens
nous sommes français et que nous avons
une très grande communauté la plus
importante communauté juive 500000
personnes de France d'Europe pardon que
nous avons la plus grande communauté
musulmane d'Europe et que le minimum du
service pour un républicain en
particulier s'il est élu à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est de ne pas ramener le
conflit en France et d'apaiser or il
n'apaise pas en particulier en faisant
ce qu'il qu'ils font donc oui c'est
c'est assez tragique parenthèse
d'ailleurs
j'ai bien compris vous ne voulez pas de
conflit importé en France et
d'importation du conflit en France
est-ce que c'était une bonne idée
d'interdire les magnifi
propalestinien je je ne sais pas quelles
étaient les raisons pour laquell est
interdite mais de en général ça n'a pas
de sens d'interdire une manifestation si
elle ne menace pas l'ordre public et
s'il n'y a pas de risque d'attentat ou
de ou de mobilisation d'éléments
dangereux mais non en plus je peux je
peux me permettre de le dire j'en ai
organisé des manifestations en soutien à
la Palestine puisque la position de la
France officiellement rappelé par le
Président de la République c'est celle
de de deux états donc il est
parfaitement légitime en France de
manifester pour l'autodétermination des
Palestiniens il y a aucun souci à cela
et donc il faut plutôt laisser se faire
les les manifestations sauf si ça part
en quenouille et que on a des propos qui
ne sont plus du dans le cadre
républicain ou des gens qui particip
qu'il n'en sont pas je reviens justement
sur des propos qui ont fait polémique
c'est les derniers propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur cette manifestation
c'était sur Twitter cette semaine je je
vous les donne dimanche manif de l'arc
républicain arc républicain entre
guillemets du RN à la macronie de Bron
pivé et sous prétexte d'antisémitisme
ramène Israël Palestine sans demander le
cesser le feu les amis du soutien
inconditionnel au massacre ont leur
rendez-vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de ces propos et que ce sont des
propos délirants c'est des propos c'est
jeter de l'huile sur le feu c'est amener
le conflit en France c'est
communautariser pourquoi parce que ceux
qui manifestent aujourd'hui ne
manifestent pas pour bombarder Gaza même
il y en a qui sont contre enfin et puis
en plus ça ne va pas que du
rassemblement national à Madame Bron
Pivet il me semble
que on a v marine Tondelier Oliv g de LV
il y a Fabien Roussel nous république
souveraine on est la gauche républicaine
on y est donc non c'est c'est les termes
déjà sont une instrumentalisationil a de
dire oh non tout ça c'est que la droite
et l'extrême droite non c'est la France
euh dans ces différentes composantes et
il refuse d'aborder le le ce pourquoi
les gens marchent qui contre
l'antisémitisme on peut parfaitement
être contre antisémitisme et et soutenir
la création d'un État palestinien al
s'il disait ça il pas de problème mais
c'est pas ça qui dit ce qu'il dit c'est
que tous ceux qui se
réunissent dans une marche contre
l'antisémitisme ce qui devrait être
normal en fait sont pour bombarder
Gaza c'est c'est au minimum fallacieux
euh mais en fait c'est une crapulerie
politique et qui qui qui qui renforce le
communautarisme dans notre pays donc
vraiment on a pas besoin estce qu'on
voit ce qui se passe en Grande-Bretagne
ou qui est un
[Musique]
pays d'intégration communautariste et
pas non et non pas d'assimilation
traditionnellement républicaine comme la
France bah on voit ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est pas très très beau un
cortège doncous sous haute protection
c'est ce que nous rappellent les
journalistes présents du Figaro sur
place on est avec George gusmanovic qui
a été le conseiller défense politique
étrangère sécurité de Jean-Luc Mélanchon
avant
d'êtrecription avant d'être avincé de la
France à j'ai pas été avincé moi
justement moi je suis parti c'est vrai
c'est vrai vous êtes formement
formalement vous êtes parti mais on vous
on vous y a invité un petit peu quand
même genre formellement je suis parti
mais publiquement c'est il me semble que
ça a été le premier coup de boutoir de
la France insoumise dans la salle des
quatre colonnes à l'époque
euh une question il y avait un certain
nombre de de députés insoumis qui se qui
se sont rassemblés mais pas à Paris hein
et non pas au veldiv ni dans cette
manifestation mais à l'appel d'un député
LFI de de Strasbourg il y avait
clémentineotin Raquel garido Alexis
corbierre François Ruffin euh ces
députés qui sont présentés quand même
comme opposants à à à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
euh
sont eux leur engagement il est sincère
ou pas dans dans la marche contre
l'antisémitisme ah mais Ruffin j'en suis
sûr à 100
% et
également également madame gardo dont
d'ailleurs je on était pas tellement
proche
mais même avant était
plutôt même qualifié de sioniste très
très en défense d'Israël de l'État
d'Israël a toujours été donc bon ça ne
semble pas
euh non c'est authentique mais bon on
voit quand même qu'ils sont un peu gênés
aux entournures et que de toute façon
cette
sission correspond à la frondte qui a
actuellement au sein de la France
insoumise et que pour pas trop en
rajouter ils viennent pas à la
manifestation de Paris mais ils auraient
parfaitement pu venir à Sal de Paris il
y a aucune voilà bon c'est c'est c'est
un sorte d'entre deux pour ne pas
fracturer totalement la France insoumise
euh Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous l'avez bien
connu vous avez dénoncé ces ces
propos est-ce que pour autant il est
antisémite vous savez c'est votre
collègue Guillaume roquet qui m'a posé
ces questions il y a très longtemps au
moment des élections européennes de 2019
suite à la note de blog qu'avait fait
jean-lucque Mélenchon par rapport à la
défaite de corbin qu'il avait dit qu'il
se Jérémy Corbin qui était Président du
enfin leader du Parti travailliste
britannique dont les propos ont toujours
été ambigu en tous les qui a très
contesté et c'est auudelà de l'ambiguïé
c'estàd qu'en 2009 il a réuni le Hamas
et le hzbollah au Commons donc au
Parlement britannique euh il est allé à
la à la à la à la grande mosquée de
Finsbury Park pour avec en faisant le le
signe de l'Arabia plusieurs fois donc le
signe de l'Arabia c'est les quatre
doigts qui sont un signe de rallimement
du Hamas il a
euh il a couvert des des problèmes
réellement d'antisémitisme dans son
mouvement au point où il y a un rapport
ce qui fait que maintenant il siège
comme député mais il n'est plus en tant
que député travailliste
bon et à l'époque j'avais dit écoutez
j'ai passénmment de temps avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon j'ai jamais entendu rien
d'antisémite de sa part à moins qu'il un
changement profond du personnage en lui
ou je ne sais pas que ce soit
le c'est ce qui est possible ça fait 5
ans que parle
plus je n'avais rien vu d'antisémite et
par contre
depuis il a des propos antisémites et le
pire d'entre eux qui moi
complètement étonné et j'aurais ét bien
embêté dans répondre à cette question
c'est quand sur BFM je crois que c'est
face à Pauline de Malerbe enfin peu
importe il dit on sait bien qui quel est
le peuple qui a crucifié Jésus qui quand
même la ligne de de l'extrême droite
française mais justement celle d'avant
des années
le le peuple déicide c'est c'est c'est
l'extre française et ça a été
euh ça n'est même plus dans la doctrine
chrétienne catholique depuis Vatican
I la
mercillaise qui retentit boulevard
[Musique]
Saint-Germain
allez ça part c'est parti les gars on
appuie voilà la manifestation qui repart
donc on va être au niveau de la la place
de l'Odéon peut-être un premier
commentaire sur donc euh
cette cette comment dire ce dispositif
qui a derrière la la bande rôle
euh pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme avec des leaders
religieux
question à à vous qui êtes un ardent
défenseur de la laïcité
oui mais
je la laïcité je vous rappelle protège
les croyances
ou ceux qui ne croi à rien donc et en
particulier dans un contexte
antisémitisme pourquoi il n'y aurait pas
justement de sorte d'cuménisme de du
respect de l'autre c'est quand même pas
c'est quand même pas dramatique je crois
pas que les religieux qui sont là
musulmans ou catholiques ou ou juif
fassent des euh des homélies des messes
ou
des des propos religieux donc ils sont
là pour aussi parler d'unité euh pas le
à l'instant ERC Zemour lui dénonce le
comportement sectaire de la gauche le
président de Recon reconquête euh qui
est donc dans
le dans la présence également à suscité
des poli moins forte que pour le
rassemblement national a déclaré c'est
culoté de la part des des de ces gens il
parlit des des responsables de gauche
qui ont tout fait pour qu'il y ait plus
d'immigrés dans notre pays je trouve ça
indesscent de leur part j'invite tous
les Français à venir mais la gauche est
secteur on le sait depuis longtemps euh
il a dénoncé le choix du vote
communautaire et l'ambiguïé antisémite
de l'extrême gauche il y a aussi sur
notre sol une population plus proche du
Hamas que de nos compatriotes Juifs
c'est ce qu'à déclaré donc Éric Zemour
post à retrouvver dans le live Tex du du
Figaro euh est-ce que euh on vous vous
disiez justement qu'il y a un certain
nombre de gens euh qui qui sont contre
euh qui peuvent critiquer euh la
politique d'Israël et qui se retrouent
dans cette manifestation à l'inverse
est-ce que parfois quand même euh
l'antisionisme
euh notamment dans les dans les rangs de
la de de la gauche et de la gauche très
propalestinienne euh ou bien même du
d'une extrême droite n'est pas un
paravant de
l'antisémitisme bon al d'abord je trouve
les les propos de derric zemou
complètement délirant et ils sont
l'exact pendant de ceux de je Mélenchon
que il Latisse les haines alors que
c'est une journée de marche contre
antisémitisme
euh je suis gauche républicaine je me
sens
insulté ce qui met toute la gauche dans
le même paquet et puis que je suis pas
sûr je suis pas sûr que soit toute la
gauche ah il dit la gauche ce que vous
avez cité c'est la gauche il précise
dans ce cas mais bon et puis il parle de
la gauche qui a unorté l'immigration
donc je pense qu'il parle il fait
référence au Parti socialiste que je
connais pas d'autres gauches qui soit
qui était au pouvoir je me souviens pas
que l'UMP ou le RPR a été a fait quoi
que ce soit sérieusement contre je me
souviens que tous ont plutôt construit
une Union européenne qui est totalement
laxiste sur l'entrée et qu' ne comit pas
vraiment h de toute façon quand bien
même monsieur Zemour arriverait au
pouvoir ce que je ne souhaite pas et
puis je pense impossible mais il oublie
que depuis le traité d'Amsterdam 1999
euh on a quasiment délégué toute notre
souveraineté sur la question migratoire
je me souvens pas que c'était je pense
que sur ce planl vous seriez d'accord
mais oui mais enfin bon c'est
intéressant de mettre toute la gauche
dans le même paquet c'est un peu comme M
qui ah non c'est toute la droite bon on
a bien compris voilà et donc pour
revenir donc sur cette question de
l'antisionisme est-ce que c'est pas
souvent aussi un paravant de
l'antisémitisme mais ça peut l'être mais
ça n'est pas toujours et
donc malheureusement je je non mais je
vaux être honnête je constate que il y a
20 ans quand on quand on
critiquait certain es actions du
gouvernement
israélien ce qui encore une fois est
légitime
désolé c'est légitime quand il y a des
exaction et bien là immédiatement on
avait un tir de barrage ah si vous
critiquez c'est que vous êtes antisémite
ça devient ridicule parce que même même
des des juif se retrouvait donc dans un
camp antisémite aucun sens mais
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a une certaine
permissivité idéologique parce
que ceux qui représentent la Palestine
qui est un combat que je dois quand même
souligner qui qui peut être important
pour des gens je j'en ai été mais prend
une ampleur beaucoup trop grande dans la
gauche pourquoi parce qu'on n'est pas
palestinien et que et que il y a c'est
utilisé comme un argument d'affrontement
avec l'Occident avec le avec
le le judéo-christianisme je suis
désolé les pour les fervants défenseurs
de la umaa là en ce moment il y a
entre 1 et 1,5 million de d'Afghans qui
sont ch c'est du Pakistan puis en mode
brutal hein ça se fait pas avec des des
des jolies enveloppes comme demande
l'Union européenne quand on veut sortir
quelqu'un du territoire français en ce
moment on est à au qtf ou non depuis le
21 septembre on au-delà on doit faire
des enfin bon c'est c'est l'arrêté du 21
septembre de la de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne et délirant je vous
invite si vous le connaissez pas à le
lire c'est folklorique euh
est on est dans les montipiton
littéralement mais donc en ce moment
vous avez une guerre au darrefour vous
avez des genjaoud qui sont des
djihadistes très proches d'ailleurs des
autres djihadistes qui massacrent des
populations noires vous avez depuis 20
ans dans le Sahel toute une série
d'organisations islamistes qui tuent des
musulmans bon ça a pas l'air de choquer
plus que ça dans dans Luma
euh on a la guerre du Yemen qui a fait
400000 morts des millions de déplacés
des des des gamins qui des millions
d'enfants qui sont mal Nutris qui qui
vont finir avec
des a diminué physiquement
intellectuellement bon c'est bah ça
inéresse
personne pas plus que ce qui se passe en
Birmanie enfin la Birmanie encore à
nouveau en ce moment il y a à nouveau un
conflit avec dans dans le nord de la
Birmanie donc c'est les roingas c'est
des musulmans aussi bon donc il y a il y
a une il y a une il y a une passion il y
a une passion sur la poli
l'Internationale de l'islam politique a
quand même soulevé avait quand même pas
mal apporté de soutien au sort des
roingas donc un peu mais bon là
aujourd'hui ça se passe à nouveau et
c'est oublié donc il y a une
trop forte polarisation polarisation sur
sur sur la crise palestinienne et puis
elle fait partie de ce que Micha
critiquait très bien dans ses
ouvragesich le
philosophe quand il parlait de cette
nouvelle gauche qui a abandonné le
prolétariat et le peuple bon se
passionne pour pour l'immigré pour le
clandestin et aussi pour des causes où a
aucune influence mais aucune on peut
manifester à 500000 dans Paris pour
qu'il ait un État palestinien c'est très
bien ça fait un poids ça fait ça fait
que ceux qui en Palestine veulent un
état peuvent se sentir soutenu quelqu
part mais en vrai ça ne change rien à la
réalité donc c'est un combat je vais
dire facile car il a très peu de
conséquences pour ceux qui le mènent
mais est-ce précisément et certains donc
je je disais certains malheureusement je
constate aujourd'hui et jeunes et ce
n'est pas si étonnant que Monsieur gurau
soit fasse partie des jeunes députés
David gu donc qui a soulevé la
polémique avec des propos qui ont été
extrêmement en tous les cas commentés et
et et pour beaucoup dénoncés euh en
Tunisie c'est pas la première fois son
meilleur ami un de ses meilleurs amis
c'est monsieur tabavs qui animé
d'ailleurs la table ronde dans lequelle
ses propos ont été tenus he surprise
monsieur tabiv qui récemment écrivait
sur je ne sais quel réseau social que il
faut que les musulmans
essentialisation des musulmans doivent
s'armer faire des milices quand même
pour se défendre puis aussi avoir leur
médias à eux là on est ultra
commmunautarisme donc c'est c'est ça ce
qui défendent et là on peut avoir des
jeunes qui ne connaissent pas qui
malheureusement le deing guerre mondiale
choix tout ça ça ça part un peu des
consciences euh je crois qu'on est à
plus d'un tiers des des jeunes de moins
de 25 ans qui qui qui ont conscience de
ce qu' a été réellement la choix c'est
c'est en France hein c'est une tragédie
euh et bien vous pouvez avoir une dérive
vers l'antisémitisme et je le constate
malheureusement je suis obligé de le
constater et ce qui fait que la la
l'accusation qui est insupportable il y
a 20 ans maintenant des fois elle est
pas insupportable mais al elle est
réelle pour rebondir sur ce que vous
disiez il ne faut pas confondre fondre
cette mobilisation avec un soutien à la
politique d'Israël ce sont des
manifestants qui s'expriment alors qu'on
voit encore l'affluence qui a sur ces
images tournées par Vincent roseron et
qui nous parviennent en direct de
l'Esplan des
Invalides élément frappant vous y étiez
tout à l'heure George kusmanovic la
mobilisation elle ne faiblit pas elle ne
s'arrête pas pour la manifestation pour
la manifestation oui ce qui est très
bien parce que voyez là il est il est
16h30 euh et donc on est c'est le pont
Alexandre enfin 3 Alexandre 3 donc c'est
vraiment la sortie des Invalides et
c'est c'est rempli donc c'est rempli
depuis depuis plus de 2 heures quoi et
c'est le point de
départ gros c'est des espaces assez
assez assez larges donc oui il y a du
monde beaucoup de monde encore vous le
voyez qui arrive et la tête de cortège
ici boulevard Saint-Germain qui encore
une fois se fait une pause avec un carré
qui est séparé en fait du reste de la
manifestation un carré qui est sous très
haute sécurité comme l'expliquai
également les journalistes sur place du
Figaro d'A je suis surpris par rapport à
la mini polémique qui avec le président
de la République qui est vraiment pas
politiquement un ami mais on vous
regrettez pas son absence mais on peut
pas avoir les quatre têtes de l'État au
même endroit au même moment c'est c'est
c'est on a ça c'est l'ancien conseill de
sécurité qui parle ah je pense que
quelqu'un il y a des gens sérieux quand
même à l' Lisée au sommet de l'État qui
ont dit ben non on peut pas là on a
quand même le président du Sénat donc
qui remplace le président en cas de
carence de la présidence pour quelle que
soit la raison puis on a le premier
ministre qui est là la première ministre
et la
présidente de l'Assemblé nationale c'est
les quatre enfin c'est dans la
Constitution si vous rajoutez le
président et que je ne sais pas par
malheur quelque chose que se passe à ce
moment-l bah on a un gros problème non
on peut pas avoir tout le monde au même
endroit au même moment c'est
c'est c'est non pas est-ce que vous
pensez est-ce que aurait pu il aurait pu
pu manifester il me semble que François
mitaran l'a fait François Hollande
également le 11 janvier 2015 après les
franis c'était Carpentras et François
mitan c'était Carpentras euh question
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron en a fait
assez avec la lettre qu'il a adressé aux
Français avec des mots assez assez forts
assez
clairs il me semble qu'il a fait le
travail qui devait être fait en tant que
président encore une fois je suis pas du
tout sur la même ligne politique que lui
mais là c'est une question sur la même
ligne queotti qui trouve qu'il en a pas
fait assez
non plus
mais il est président et il doit
justement garantir l'unité nationale
donc il s'est exprimé sur une critique
claire de l'antisémitismeç je vois pas
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait pu faire d'autre
mais donc non c'est
c'est com pas très bien la polémique en
fait certains témoignages font état en
tous les cas sont été recueillis et
effectivement de gens qui viennent
marcher contre l'antisémitisme et qui
disent que c'est pas non plus un soutien
à l'État d'Israël
euh et qui sont également frappés par le
sentiment de peur qui habite un certain
nombre de de juifs français est-ce que
là aussi il y a pas une évolution depuis
une vingtaine d'années georgees
kusmanovic qui malgré les
manifestations depuis les années 2000
depuis le début de la 2è Intifada on est
à la 3è manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme et là on vient de
constater un nombre record de d'actes
antisémites rien que depuis le 7 mars
dernier est-ce à quoi servent ce genre
de manifestation est-ce que c'est le
gouvernement est présent
massivement les responsables politiques
qui sont au pouvoir depuis 20 ans sont
présents à cette manifestation mais
n'ont-ils pas échoué est-ce que cette
manifestation derrière ça derrière le
succès peut-être que l'on est en train
d'observer il y a pas un échec qui est
l'échec de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et le désir de revenir
en Israël alors même que au lendemain du
7 mars ce même qui avaiit fait leur
allat euh le retour en Israël disait que
peut-être ils avaient eu tort de le
faire et que le 7 octobre et que c'était
pas forcément le sanctuaire qu'ils
imaginer alors d'abord je confirme par
exemple république souveraine a appelé
ses militants et sympathisants à venir
et que c'est une marche contre
l'antisémitisme ce n'est pas une marche
en soutien à euh à la politique du
gouvernement
israélien oui mais on est obligé de le
faire parce que comme la France
insoumise a tellement tiré en disant que
le participer à cette marche c'est de
facto soutenir le gouvernement netaniao
on est obligé de le dire parce que à
force de l'entendre vous on se retrouve
avec des militants qui oui mais est-ce
qu'il y a pas un risque queon soit
associé à non il y a aucun risque bon
maintenant ce que vous dites est tout à
fait juste on a on est on a un recul
grave de la République des valeurs de la
République Samuel Patti s'est fait
égorger pardon assassiné décapité par un
terroriste islamiste on en a un autre
qui cherchait des des des des
enseignants des professeurs
d'histoire et la vérité c'est
que cette année entre autres c'est déjà
dur par ailleurs mais enseigner la choix
dans certaines
classes ça va être spécial et j'ai pas
entendu qu'il a spécialement de
protection ou
de que le gouvernement fasse quelque
chose pour d'abord que ce soit
réellement enseigné et qu'on ait pas
cette cette perte de conscience de de ce
quiétait l'olocos la choix et les crimes
nazis on a quand même des apologies du
nazisme à d'itler dans des classes des
professeurs vous racontent ça des petit
gamin qui bah non était super bon là
encore là tout à l'heure un enseignant
de notre de notre mouvement qui me dit
bah non je me suis retrouvé devant ça
c'est compliqué il faut et là-dessus il
y a du pas de vague encore
donc on a on a un recul communautariste
dans notre pays on est
malheureusement bon ce serait trop long
de développer ici mais vous avez le
temps de le faire vous pourriez aller
non mais on est de manière générale
depuis une trentaine d'années sous une
influence anglo-saxone culturellement
dans management des entreprises dans le
vocabulaire les management dans notre
vocabulaire dans notre
façon de faire de voir la politique et
on a de plus en plus de
jeunes qui sont nourris ce qui nétait
pas notre cas à haute dose avec des
séries sont surtout américaines et sont
écrites par des anglo-saxons et donc qui
véhiculent leur
valeur on a le développement de
l'individualisme
du est-ce que le problème en
l'occurrence c'est pas le le le le
développement de d'un certain islamisme
qui qui non mais justement jeis venir
les attitude du victimaire et donc on en
arrive à
à cette moins en moins bonne intégration
par
l'assimulation pas le cas pour tout le
monde he parce que on a énormément de
français de religions musulmanes qui
malgré les difficultés économique malgré
être né dans des mauvais quartiers sont
devenus pour qui ministre pour qui
médecin pour qui enseignant professeur
d'université alors qu' partait de
famille qui étaient pas vraiment qui
était tout en bas dans l'échelle sociale
donc bon on a quand même un système
d'intégration qui je pense est le
meilleur au monde mais malgré tout on a
laissé partir toute une série de
quartiers comm on a dit perdu de la
République euh et laisser s'installer là
où où il manquait du travail où il
manquait des services publics les
islamistes qui
eux on voit bien comment il savent faire
avec comme le Hamas et le hbollah ils
s'occupe de la
communauté d'aider les familles de de
trouver des petits boulot petit à petit
il s'instalent et le le laisser faire
par rapport au Frères musulmans est
délirant dans ce pays on a madame flance
berge bler qui a écrit un livre
là-dessus on a le professeur Ali qui est
le spécialiste égyptien des Frères
musulmans on a laissé faire une
infiltration des Frères musulmans
jusqu'à la Commission européenne quand
même la campagne sur le voile pro voile
faite par l'Union européenne est
délirante donc quand vous avez ça
oui évidemment vous
avez le développement du communitarisme
et de l'affrontement avec les Juifs qui
sont mis en comme cible pour certains
parce que sans aucune raison car la
plupart ne sont pas Palestiniens
intériorisent le combat palestinien
euh comme étant le leur et donc il se
sentent en droit étant en France de
s'attaquer à des Juifs qui eux sont
français pour la plupart donc sont pas
israéliens non plus
euh c'est une chose d'avoir chacun ses
préférences au niveau international
c'est autre chose d'importer les
conflits or ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
a laissé faire de l'import du conflit en
France et qui est fait par des
islamistes c'est pour ça que je dis
disait le problème de la France
insoumise c'est qu'ils sont contre
l'antisémitisme d'avant et pas contre
l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui est-ce que
je sais que c'est dur à dire c'est dur à
entendre parfois mais quand même vous
avez eu
des des propos et et des analyses quand
même très
claires on va écouter de nouveau les
marseillaise on revient juste
après
élevés les candard sanglant élevés
entendez-vous dans nos campagnes
M S féoc soldats qui vienent jusque dans
nos bras et gorger nos fils et nos
compagnes aux
[Applaudissements]
es
citoyens le
bataillons
marchons
un à
breu
[Musique]
l'on voilà plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui sont réunies plusieurs
dizaines même de milliers de personnes
qui sont réunies dans les rues de Paris
également dans les autres villes de
France à l'heure actuelle alors que vous
voyez donc la tête de cortège de de
cette manifestation alors on voyait tout
à l'heure des images aériennes la tête
de cortège séparé du reste de cortège
donc vous voyez la queue sur ces images
qui sont tournées par Vincent reoseron
là cette queue de cortège qui se trouve
elle encore à l'heure actuelle sur le
point de départ de cette manifestation
manifestation qui est partie depuis plus
d'unh et3 he à 15h très exactement et
vous voyez encore des gens euh sur place
on va essayer de retrouver d'ailleurs
Vincent roseron qui se tourne
actuellement ses images Vincent pardon
je vous pose encore la question mais
parce que je le constate la mobilisation
elle ne faiblit
pas euh non effectivement elle ne
faiblit pas alors je je me suis avancé
je ne suis plus à l'ESP des Invalides je
suis maintenant devant l'Assemblée
nationale attendez je vais vous montrer
je vais tourner un peu la caméra l'ESP
des invalid l'Assemblée nationale qui
est juste ici avec les gens qui avancent
petit à petit c'est toujours pareil
depuis le début deette manifestation on
regarde comment on peut avancer pour
regarder du réseau pour que je puisse
discuter avec vous mais donc oui
beaucoup de gens vous le voyez sur ces
images inf flux ininterrompu de personne
c'est assez dense sur la route et
beaucoup de gens qui sont présents donc
à cette
manifestation et on espère avoir
justement un témoignage de ces personnes
je sais que c'est assez compliqué
puisque comme il y a beaucoup de monde
les images figent et c'est pas un
problamme qui est spécifique au Figaro
c'est un problème qu'on toutes les
chaînes de télé qui sont sur place et
également les agences comme la FP qui
nous enenvoyaé tout à l'heure des
petites images qui qui montraient des
ruvines mais c'était parce que c'est les
seules qu'on pouvait tourner à ce
moment-l euh sinon les images encore une
fois figé pourquoi elles figent parce
qu'il y a énormément de monde il y a
énormément de réseaux tout ça c'est les
mêmes réseaux hein à la fois les
téléphones portables Internet les images
qui sont envoyées depuis depuis les lieu
même où elles sont tournées euh et donc
la il y a du monde sur la bande passante
et donc c'est un signe de cette de cette
affluence merci beaucoup Vincent alors
effectivement vous êtes pas encore place
sur l'ADE des invalides mais quand on
est devant l'Assemblée nationale on
n'est pas loin et on voit également sur
ces images et bien la le boulevard
Saint-Germain qui est plein boulevard
Saint-Germain boulevard Saint-Michel qui
sont les trajets de cette manifestation
où se trouvait également tout à l'heure
George kusmanovic qui est euh avec nous
George kmanovic qui dirige un petit
mouvement qui s'appelle République
sociale etverain république souveraine
mais vous êtes social sociau aussi voilà
donc république souveraine et qui a été
conse vous avez été dans le temps
également conseiller euh défense et
sécurité de Jean-Luc Mélenchon euh vous
plusieurs membres de votre
euh de votre de votre mouvement sont
sont présents
euhz
on on le disait c'est c'est la toute la
question toute la on voit bien le le le
le succès en tous les cas pas
apparemment le ce qui va être le succès
de cette manifestation qui est
semble-t-il sur le point d'arrivver euh
mais à
l'inverse ce que l'on voit c'est que les
manifestations là apparemment un petit
toujours la tension habituelle quand on
tourne euh
les tension pour les caméras c'est un
passage obligé euh et on essaiera
d'avoir d'ailleurs jean-if Camu tout à
l'heure en en plateau qui nous donnera
son son analyse et et son commentaire il
était également présent à la
manifestation je reviens encore une fois
sur cette sur ce sur ce phénomène
euh aujourd'hui euh Marine Le Pen et le
front rassemblement national est
massivement présent à cette
manifestation ils tiennent à montrer
leur leur présence pour la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme on rappelle en
1990 la la manifestation à après la
profonation du cimetière juif de
carpantra Visé à dénoncer un un un
antisémitisme de résurgence de de
résurgence des années 30
et d'extrême droite euh ensuite
euh le la bralation de Carpentra reste
largement enfin à donneré matière à à à
polémique également mais enfin en tous
les cas à l'époque on reprochait au
Front national son antisémitisme et les
propos de Jean-Marie Le Pen aujourd'hui
le rassemblement national est là en
revanche depuis les années 2000 on on
dénonce alors on écoute peut-être Gérard
Larcher et on y revient juste après pour
ce travail que nous avons fait et qui
lui est parti du cœur je voulais lui
dire que le cœur et la raison en vous
remerciant tous en remerciant les
anciens présidents de la République en
remerciant les anciens Premier ministre
et président d'assemblée qui sont ici
présents les membres du gouvernement et
je voudrais saluer les les personnalités
de notre société civile et culturelle
qui font vivre des valeurs des valeurs
que l'homme et la femme c'est autre
chose qu'une valeur matérielle c'est
aussi ce qui nous rassemble merci à tous
faudra pas simplement que ça soit une
marche faut qu'une marche conduise à une
démarche et cette démarche doit nous
conduire à plus que jamais les valeurs
de la la République soit au cœur de
notre
engagement je ne sais pas si ma voix est
porte autant que celle du président
Larcher je suis très heureuse en tant
que présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir mené cette action
concerté depuis le début avec le
président du Sénat il nous a semblé
extrêmement important fondamental d'agir
ensemble de porter la voix de nos
assemblées de porter pour lui la voix
des territoires pour nous la voix de la
nation les citoyens que nous
représentons à travers nos fonctions
respective car nous pensons que la
République les valeurs dans lesquelles
nous croyons sont menacés et que nous
avions besoin collectivement d'un
sursaut
nous avons souhaité incarner ce surceaut
permettre à tous de se rassembler autour
de nous et je voudrais remercier
l'ensemble des personnes qui nous
accompagnent aujourd'hui et qui ont
répondu extrêmement rapidement à cet
appel puisque rappelez-vous cet appel a
été lancé mardi dans la presse nous en
avons décidé du principe lundi dernier
c'était il y a simplement 6 jours et moi
je voudrais vous dire que c'est
extrêmement réjouissant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui en France nous sommes
capables de nous rassembler aussi
rapidement de nous réunir autour de ce
qui fait notre socle de ce qui a fait
notre histoire et ce qui fera j'en suis
sûre notre avenir et moi je suis
extrêmement confiante parce que
aujourd'hui nous avons montré la plus
belle image de la France tous ensemble
quel que soi nos partis politiques
quel que soi nos parcours politiques et
c'est aussi ça que nous voulions montrer
avec le président du Sénat et moi-même
que nous savions tout dépasser pour
pouvoir nous rassembler pour ce qui
était de plus précieux et je suis
heureuse nous sommes heureux que nos
concitoyens a répondu très largement à
cet appel car c'est avant tout pour eux
que nous avons marché je vous
remercie
[Musique]
re
min par etsieur et monsieur le Président
c'est important aussi de pouvoir dire
c'est un succès vous vivez comme
ça le cortège é pas encore par les
Invalides donc je pense que ça montre
qu'en effet de très nombreux citoyens
sont mobilisé pour répondre à la Phe qui
été lancée par le président du Sénat et
la présidente de l'Assemblée évidemment
c'était important pour moi d'être là
avec mon gouvernement
pour inquiété en raison de son origine
et de sa religion et qu'c le
gouvernement avec tous les ministres
nous voulons dire à nos concitoyens de
religion juif que nous sommes à leur
côté nous sommes mobilisés que nous ne
laisserons rien passer il y aura des
démarches derrière c'est ce qu'a dit le
président Larcher pas seulement une
marche mais des démarches qu'est-ce
qu'il veut dire écoutez le président
Larcher expliquera les démarche qu'il a
en tête moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que les policiers les gendarmes
les magistrats sont très mobilisés pour
ne laisser passer aucun message de haine
pour ne laisser évidemment pas passer
aucune violence à l'égard d'un de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il est de religion
juive donc on est on ne laisse rien
passer on est au côté de nos concitoyens
de religion Ju merci Madame la PR merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]
beaucoupciadameadame parce que c'est
vraiment une démarche commune qu'on a eu
depuis notre début l'idée est venue
d'une discussion que nous avons eu lundi
dernier et nous avons décidé depuis 6
jours d'avancer ensemble donc voilà
c'est nous nos chambres nos institutions
qui sont à l'initiative et on est
tellement
heureux et rassuré de voir que les
Français ont répondu présent on a été
frappé par l'émotion qu'il y avait même
entre vous pendant que vous marchiez le
silence l'émotion avec Nicolas Sarkozy
avec François Holland vous l'avez
ressenti comme ça oui on l'a ressenti
parce que c'est un moment qui est grave
et il y a beaucoup d'émotions positives
aussi parce que les Français ont su se
rassembler nous l'avons senti au fur à
mesure que nous avancionss dans le
cortège les nouvelles nous parvenait de
ce rassemblement populaire et savoir que
les Français ont répondu à notre appel
et bien ça fait chaud au cœur et puis ça
veut dire que nous sommes dans le vrai
et vous savez quand on est responsable
politique c'est important de savoir
pourquoi on agit et quand on agit juste
et bien c'est très réconfortant et ça
nous vous avez été personnellement prise
pour cible et notamment ciblé
systématiquement quasiment par Jean-Luc
Mélançon vous l'avez vécu comment
écoutez ça m'iffère en fait les attaques
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est en train de
tout salir aujourd'hui et donc
je ne ferai pas d'autres commentaires je
vous remercie merci
beaucoup Bron privé la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui vient donc de
réagir les premiers propos donc du
président du Sénat de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui sont arrivés
donc sur la place mond Rostan qui est le
point d'arrivée de cette manifestation
une foule immense rassemblée à Paris
contre l'antisémitisme c'est ce que
rapporte les journalistes qui sont sur
place est ce que nous pouvons voir sur
les images alors bien sûr qui sont
toujours des images plus de planans plus
ou moins serré mais on l'a pu le
constater tout à l'heure en voyant
encore une foule nombreuse une foule
compacte sur euh devant l'Assemblée
nationale alors que s'exprime l'ancien
président de la République François
Hollande onécoute on revient juste après
ça doit montrer que la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'est une valeur
partagée comme la lutte contre tous les
racismes c'était ce ce chance là que je
voulais moi faire apparaître dans le
succès de cette manifestation en
l'urence président de la République
actuelle le problème n'est pas tant qui
était pas là qui était là ce qui était
là c'était les Français c'est ça qui
comptait d'abord trois marseillaises
beaucoup de drapeaux français on les a
vu ça s'était pas vu depuis longtemps
dans dans les rues de Paris qu'est-ce
que vous ça vous inspire si ça c'était
vu souvenez-vous lorsqu'il y a eu la
grande manifestation hélas après que la
rédaction de Charlie a été décimée que
l'hypercacher a été attaqué avec des
prises de Tage et des morts après que
des policiers éent été tués j'avais
demandé que les Français puissent mettre
des drapeaux aux fenêtres bah ils ont dû
les garder parce qu'il y en avait
beaucoup sur le sur le parcours et puis
il y avait beaucoup de drapeau français
dans la manifestation parce que ce qui
nous unit c'est c'est pas simplement un
drapeau c'est ce qu'il représente c'est
la valeur de la liberté et la valeur
aussi de la dignité humaine c'est en
sens que l'antisémitisme est une
atteinte
à ce drapeaau là et et à la République
merci à vous à
bientôt voilà donc François Hollande qui
s'est exprimé qui a fait allusion à la
grande manifestation du 11 janvier 2015
Jonathan Harfi également président du
CRIF on
l'écoute chacun se sente concerné parce
que le combat contre l'antisémitisme
n'est pas que l'affaire des Juifs c'est
bien entendu un symptôme d'une société
française qui doute qui va mal et l'élan
de cette journée c'est celui qui
consiste à faire que demain nous soyons
engagés dans un combat collectif pour
restaurer les valeurs républicaine et
construire un avenir de concorde
ensemble à partir de ce moment-là de
cette de cette dynamique qui s'est créée
aujourd'hui est-ce que les polémique sur
l'absence de la France insoumise ou la
présence du racemb National sont oublié
maintenant à la fin de cette
manifestation ce qui compte à l'issue de
cette manifestation c'est d'abord le
chiffre euh de mobilisation des Français
c'est aussi la dimension politique qui
allait au-delà des clivages qui s'est
affirmé le fait que les Français a
répondu présent également de manière
populaire c'est un point qui est
important vous savez face à à
l'antisémitisme le le pire pour les
Juifs c'est de se sentir seul et par
cette mobilisation c'est ce murl qui qui
est tombé aujourd'hui l'idée que il y a
des gens en France qui ont compris ce
qui se passait qui ont compris que ces
actes antisémites ne menaçaient pas que
les Juifs mais bien la société française
tout entière vous parlez des Français le
premier d'entre eux Emmanuel Macron
n'était pas là vous le regrettez j'avais
appelé à ce qu'il participe à cette
marche il a choisi un autre format la
publication d'un d'un courrier avec des
mots des mots forts évidemment sa
présence aurait rendu cet événement
encore plus historique puisqu'il
l'aurait inscrit dans dans la séquence
de la mobilisation de 2015 de celle de
90 après la profanation du cimetière de
Carpentra
c'est ainsi mais le principal est de
savoir qui sera demain pour pouvoir
engager le combat contre l'antisémitisme
1200 actes antisémites en 5 semaines
c'est l'équivalent de de à 3 années
d'antisémitisme qui se sont déversés en
quelques jours seulement en
France 1250 actes antisémite
l'équivalent de 2 à
3 ans de antisémite en quelques jours
c'est c'est effectivement
énorme avec une explosion des actes
antisémites dans les années
précédentes tous les ans il y avait une
augmentation des actes antisémites donc
là là c'est délirant mais il y avait
déjà une augmentation alors qu'on
faisait une focale sur
l'islamophobie finalement quand on
compare le en proportion largement plus
d'actes
antisémite si on rapporte à la
population que d'actes qualifieré
l'islamophobe euh pour autant pierre
bernbum qui est un grand spécialiste de
ces questionsl disait dans le Figaro que
pour l'instant il n'y a pas encore de
moment antisémite il a écrit un livre
qui s'appelle le moment antisémite euh à
la fin du 19e siècle il n'y a pas de
moment antisémite euh en France euh
qu'il y a des actes antisémites mais
qu'il n'y a pas en tous les cas un un
antisémitisme dans la dans la dans
l'opinion française et euh dans la
société
française
heureusement c'est d'ailleurs les
mobilisations de ce genre où rappeler
que
l'antisémitisme n'est pas acceptable
dans notre République et en France font
que justement il y a pas de moment
antisémite et si on arrive à un moment
antisémite c'est la situation est très
très grave euh aujourd'hui on a on a on
a manifesté contre la République pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme
pardon est-ce que surtout cet
antisémitisme n'est pas justement
aujourd'hui cette résurgence de cette an
sémitisme et on l' on l'a constaté c'est
ce qu'on a on a vu George ensemble c'est
la persistance et l'augmentation de cet
antisémitisme depuis le le les années
2000 depuis 20 ans n'est pas le signe
justement c'est pas c'est pas un
problème non seulement de de République
mais c'est c'est c'est un problème même
plus profond c'est c'est un problème de
France c'estd c'est pas le fait
justement de cette importation massive
avec des représentations qui sont
différentes et qui sont quand même liées
notamment à l'immigration massive qu'on
connaît en France depuis des décennies
surtout l'évolution de l'islam politique
le renforcement de l'islam politique
dans notre pays à la faveur
à la FA de l'immigration et pas que je
la capé de Monsieur Erdogan qui est une
des têtes des Frères musulmans finance
des associations dans notre pays sans
que ça ça n semble déranger les pouvoirs
publics depuis des 20 ans maintenant bon
on a on a fermé Milie gurus mais bon
c'était c'était parce que c'était devenu
trop même même
même de manière beaucoup trop visible
mais c'est le progrès de cette Islam
politique et qui qui entre autres a pour
émi le Juif donc c'est les actes
antisémites sont bien sûr il y a un
antisémitisme d'extrême droite
résiduel les imbéciles sont les
imbéciles avant qu'ils finissent au
Tombo ben il continuent euh à faire ce
qu'il faisait avant mais c'est résiduel
en France et donc c'est c'est
principalement le fait et encore une
fois pas des musulmans parce que moi je
me refuse à faire ce que fait ce que
font justement certains responsables
politiques comme la France insoumise à a
essentialisé un
groupe de citoyens c'est une partie
minoritaire mais extrêmement agissante
de l'islam politique qui est responsable
de cet antisémitisme et du fait que ça
se passe mal à l'école et que c'est
compliqué à l'école les valeurs
d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos ça c'est une
tragédie mais nombre de nos concitoyens
juifs ont des problèmes à mettre leurs
enfants dans certaines écoles donc soit
il les mett dans des écoles privées
confessionnelles soit des écoles privées
soit dans des quartiers où le risque est
moindre c'est ça qui est intéressant
sera peut-être une de mes dernières
questions c'est que quel est le lieu
justement aujourd'hui où l'antisémitisme
est le plus fort sans être pourtant
forcément visible c'est l'école je crois
que c'est l'école malheureusement c'est
là c'est pas pour rien que je disais
tout à l'heure il faudra non seulement
marcher d'ailleurs je rappelle que c'est
pas qu'à Parison rappelle 73
rassemblements plusieurs milliers de
personnes notamment à Strasbourg à Lyon
à Nice on le signal association des m de
France non mais c'est important de dire
parceon mon tou les images à Paris mais
en fait c'est c'est vraiment c'est
national mais au-delà de ces
mobilisations
au-delà de tout ce qu'on dit tous des
belles phrases l'engagement républicain
ce qui est très très bien et nécessaire
c'est demain après-demain le mois
prochain au quotidien qu'il faudra
lutter contre cet antisémitisme et
d'abord à l'école merci beaucoup George
kousmanovic d'être passé d'être sorti de
la manifestation d'être venu sur le
plateau du Figaro vous retournez
manifester manifester attention parce
que apparemment on a du mal à avoir
jean-lif ku parce qu'il a du mal à
s'exfiltrer de la manifestation voyez
oui je confirme c déjà compliqué de
sortir c'était compliqué de sortir donc
euh mais en tout cas vous pouvez
apparemment y aller parce qu'il y a
encore du monde qui est sur place et qui
est se trouve devant l'Assemblée
nationale on va essayer d'ailleurs de
retrouver Vincent roseron sur place euh
si les images ne sont pas figées du fait
de du caractère compact de de cette
foule
euh est-ce que voilà Vincent roseron
quel est le comment ça se passe là où
vous
êtes autour de vous est-ce que vous
m'entendez
alors que V va nous rejoindre et que GE
vient de nous quitter
oui Vincent alors je sais pas si c'est
vous m parliez parce que ça couours dans
cette
manifestation voz là où de la pluie
vient d'arriver euh on je sais pas si
vous m'entendez oui on vous
entend mais en tout cas mais en tout cas
voilà j'ai dépassé l'Assemblée nationale
comme vous voyez sur ce ce ce ces images
le cortège continue d'avancer euh il il
il avance il est toujours très compact
euh les les manifestants ne sont pas du
tout encore arrivés euh à au point de au
point d'arrivée qui est qui est qui est
le sa
comme vous le savez et et voilà et donc
du coup nous avons c'est ces
manifestants qui continuent d'avancer je
vais essayer de vous en trouver un un
pour discuter avec lui dans quelques
instants merci beaucoup Vincent et
effectivement on essaiera de de de vous
avoir dès que vous serez avec quelqu'un
et pendant ce temps-là on a le plaisir
de retrouver Véronique ressult avec nous
présidente excellente présidente de
backbon consulting l'Obs observateur
l'Observatoire euh de des réseaux
sociaux et également partenaire du
sondage hebdomadaire avec odox
l'Institut odoxa pour Le Figaro
euh Véronique je vais être un peu
provoque mais j'ai l'impression que
quand même il y a un grand vainqueur de
cette journée malgré les polémique malr
c'est quand même le rassemblement
national c'est un peu provoque c'est
vrai
je sais pas si c'est le grand gagnant en
tout cas le grand gagnant ce sont les
citoyens et la réalité d'une
mobilisation bien au-delà de ce qu'on
pouvait attendre bien au-delà de la
pluie et bien au-delà d'une forme de
politisation que rejetaient les citoyens
est-ce que c'est le grand gagnant on va
dire que si le propos de ne pas aller à
cette manifestation à cette marche était
de démontrer que le rassemblement
national n'avait pas sa place et bien on
va dire que il n'y a pas cette
démonstration aujourd'hui donc grand
gagnant je sais pas en tout cas
certainement pas perdant non
effectivement on voit énormément de
mobilisation est-ce que mobilisation
dans la rue est-ce que avant de voir
comment
est restituer cette mobilisation dans la
rues et dans les rues est-ce que ça se
mobilise également sur les réseaux
sociaux oui ça se mobilise sur les
réseaux sociaux alors déjà pour relayer
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure il n'y
a pas que Paris donc vous avez des
Facebook live et et des relais un peu
partout des manifestations et des images
et manifestations qu'il y a un peu
partout dans la France et puis il y a eu
énormément de commentaires pendant les
jours qu'on précédé et depuis ce matin
des partage d'images de témoignag de
ceux qui ne peuvent pas aujourd'hui
marcher mais qui ont envie d'être là et
de et de soutenir le mouvement et
surtout beaucoup de commentaires qui
rappellent que ça n'était pas un sujet
de pour ou contre Israël mais bien un
sujet de pour ou contre l'antisémitisme
comme il y a pe de gens qui sont
pour est-ce que il y a il y a un
ressenti sur les réseaux sociaux que il
y a en tout cas un problème
euh d'antisémitisme aujourd'hui est-ce
que cette idé quand même passe dans dans
dans l'opinion et et et a pénétré le
corps social elle a pénétré le corps
social et elle est même assez
pernicieuse parce que souvent au nom de
l'antisémitisme euh on a des gens qui
vont contourner et qui vont dire des
choses qui parfois sont pires en disant
je ne peux pas dire ce que je pense
parce que je serais taxé d'antisémite
euh c'est quelque chose de parfois plus
violent encore que l'antisémitisme
lui-même quand il est exprimé aussi
enfin plus clairement et puis on a un
sujet qui est hormis quelques
expressions qui sont nettement
repérables par l'intelligence
artificielle et qui permettent une
modération le reste du temps c'est
souvent insidieux c'est des images des
phrases des sous-entendus donc oui il y
a une forme d'antisémitisme latin qui
monte qui s'exprime de plus en plus et
avec de moins en moins on va dire de
nuances dans sur les réseaux sociaux euh
est-ce que il y a également la
conscience que l'anti enfin
l'antisémitisme devient un problème et
une forme en tous les cas c'est ce que
c'était l'un des messages aujourd'hui
une forme d'injustice
c'est-à-dire pas de raison que les Juifs
de France payent pour la politique
israélienne Rais aucune raison et et
surtout aucune raison dans leur
quotidien parce qu'on a aujourd'hui donc
des des des Juifs français qui ne
peuvent plus mettre leur mesousa de peur
d'Ur des gens qui n'osent plus donner
leur nom des gens qui ont peur et qui
cach ça est-ce qu'on a constaté alors ça
c'est un phénomène très intéressant le
figaron faisait état cette semaine donc
des personnes de confession juivees ou
avec des des noms qui peuvent donner
juste à consonance juive qui ne donneent
pas leur vrai nom de peur de ne pas être
livré par un certain nombre de
d'entreprises de de livraison comm on va
pas les citer mais enfin on les connait
toutes et parce que en tout cas c'est ce
qui se dit sur les réseaux je ne sais
pas si c'est vrai mais c'est la réalité
de témoignage souvent
partagés on en fait beaucoup état on
fait état aussi du fait que désormais ça
devient compliqué de laisser sa musza
parce que ça indique clairement à
l'extérieur que dans le foyer il y a
donc une famille de confession juives et
donc les gens ont peur la réalité aussi
du port des signes extérieurs alors sans
aller jusqu'à laakipa je disais ce matin
pas mal de témoignages de gens qui
disent qu'ils osent même plus porter la
croix de David autour du coup donc on
voit bien oui il y a quelque chose de
l'ORD de la peur quoi et d'une peur qui
monte et qui est fort injuste de fait
parce que il n'y a aucune raison en soi
pour que tout d'un coup le camp de la
peur soit soit aussi clairement
identifié on va y revenir justement je
voudrais qu'on revienne qu'on retrouve
pardon Vincent roseron qui est dans au
cœur de la manifestation et qui est même
avec un manifestant c'est bien ça
Vincent oui complètement je suis avec
Estelle qui est avec moi en ce moment on
avance ensemble comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images Estelle pourquoi
pour vous c'était important de venir à
cette manifestation mais je crois que
c'est très important qu'on réaffirme les
valeurs de notre République qu'on
réaffirme que la France c'est un pays où
on peut vivre en paix quelle que soit sa
confession religieuse et voilà moi je
suis ni ni enfin je suis attâé mais en
même temps aujourd'hui ben je me sens
complètement mobilisé contre
l'antisémitisme voilà et la République
et la République et la République et il
y a marqué sur votre petit petit panneau
nous sommes tous des des Juifs français
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu dans cette
manifestation depuis que que vous êtes
est-ce que vous êtes surpris de la
mobilisation par exemple ah mais c'est
impressionnant ça fait on est parti
depuis 2h on a fait à peine 1 komètre il
y a un monde
incroyable je crois que voilà la France
est vraiment représentée là dans cette
marche ce que j'ai vu bah c'est des gens
qui sont heureux qui ont envie de
manifester en fait leur volonté de pai
des personnes aussi qui souhaitent que
les otages soient libérés ça ce serait
quand même pas mal voilà mais je crois
qu'il y a vraiment par ce que ce qui me
touche c'est c'est l'union en fait c'est
l'Union des
Français autour des valeurs de la
République encore une fois très bien
merci beaucoup en tout
cas merci beaucoup Vincent et on espère
avoir d'autres témoignages merci
beaucoup à Estelle d'avoir témoigné en
direct sur le site du Figaro et de nous
avoir partagé
les raisons de sa présence aujourd'hui
question
euh sur d'abord peut-être une
information puisqu'on parlait des autage
à l'heure actuelle Benjamin netaniahou a
donné une interview
au médiia NBC médiia américain il me
semble
NBC à la chaîne NBC tout à fait qui où
il a répondu qu'il pourrait y avoir un
accord potentiel sur les autents je
pense le moins je m'exprime sur le sujet
plus j'augmente les chances que cela se
matérialise c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
Premier ministre israélien sur cette
question des otage on revient à la
situation française on revient à la
manifestation aux manifestations
puisqu'il y a plusieurs rassemblements
aujourd'hui contre l'antisémitisme et
pour la République c'est le modordre de
ces rassemblements et énormément de
personnes à Paris on a pas encore les
chiffres je les guettete comme le lait
sur le feu ici sur le site et Véronique
s bien évidemment parce qu'elle a tout
tous les réseaux sociaux qui sont réunis
sur son petit portable mais qui est bien
puissant et aussi puissant que les
outils d'analyse de backbone Consulting
qui est votre structure votre
organisation Véronique qui analyse
justement les mouvements des réseaux
sociaux alors précisément sur cette
question comment cette manifestation que
nous sommes en train de voir et à
laquelle n nous que nous observons est
traité
sur les les réseaux sociaux à l'heure
actuelle est-ce que elle fait le buzz et
est-ce que la question de la
mobilisation est une question qui
intéresse les les personnes qui qui
s'expriment sur les réseaux alors oui
elle fait le buzz et elle enfin la
question de la mobilisation était plus
une inquiétude hier et ce matin cet
après-midi chacun se réjouit à
l'impression que effectivement on attend
tous les chiffres comme vous euh mais
mais les Français ont l'impression que
c'est plutôt une réussite et il y a
beaucoup de témoignages qui sont dans la
manifestation de gens qui expriment à
quel point ça se passe dans un un cadre
apaisé qui a pas de slogan que il y a
beaucoup d'applaudissements que il y a
une forme d'amabilité les uns envers les
autres et et et d'apaisement sans doute
quelque chose dont on a particulièrement
besoin alors visiblement toutes les
manifestations sont pas aussi apaisées
parce que je lisais que sur la
manifestation à Nice c'est un tout petit
peu plus compliqué mais globalement euh
voilà ce soir euh ou en tout cas en fin
de journée les Français ont l'impression
que c'est une réussite et que la
République est représentée et que cette
marche est et bien une marche citoyenne
qui s'est passé dans le silence et la
dignité pour le moment est-ce que la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme est une cause qui tient
à cœur dans l'opinion
oui oui mais mon petit moment
d'hésitation est que il y a quelque
chose d'assez clivé quand même euh que
c'est un peu compliqué euh dire que
c'est une cause qui mobilise tous les
français serait exagéré disons que bien
souvent on avait plus
d'expression pro palestinienne et une
réalité d'une d'un sentiment de besoin
de se positionner dans un conflit qui
est loin et qui est complexe aujourd'hui
c'était pas ça aujourd'hui c'était un
sujet qui allait au-delà de ce conflit
et qui est un sujet sur l'antisémitisme
seulement et ce qui fait que les les
messages sont globalement plus puissants
autour de l'antisémitisme que lorsque
l'on par dans des débats autour du
conflit lui-même alors ça c'est très
c'est très très très très intéressant ce
que vous dites toujours ce que vous
dites cher Véronique mais le si je vous
suis il y a dès
qu'on ça concerne un conflit et c'est ce
qu'on appelle en média la loi de
proximité donc plus c'est loin moins ça
intéresse moins ça
impliqueensible et moins c'est et en
plus moins c'est compréhensible euh et
euh à l'inverse donc là il y a quelque
chose qui
euh il y a quelque chose qui interpelle
les gens parce qu'il y a une proximité
donc j'en viens enfin si je suis la
logique c'est que s'il y a une proximité
c'est pas très rassurant ça veut dire
que il y a un sentiment que il y a
quelque chose de de d'anormal qui se
passe chez nous à l'heure actuelle c'est
c'est la réalité de alors vous vous
demandiez à votre invité précédent si
c'était euh où était le lieu de cet
antisémitisme le plus latent le moins
visible et le plus difficile vous
conveniez que c'était à l'école et
effectivement on sent bien il il y a
quelque chose dans la société qui qui
s'est fracturé et qui devient très
concret et chacun même les les gens qui
ne sont pas de confession Juifs voi bien
la réalité de ce qui est en train de
monter et ça c'est totalement dissocié
de la réalité du conflit en soi avec un
petit bémol qui est que généralement
quand on commence à parler
d'antisionisme c'est qu'on n pas loin de
l'antisémitisme et on voit bien qu'il y
a quelque chose de complexe dans cette
relation tout le débat c'est toute la
question qu'on a posé cet après-midi
avec
effectivement le toute cette toute cette
question complexe aussi autour de de
l'antisionisme et de l'antisémitisme
euh une chose très frappante dans ce que
vous dites c'est que il y a un lieu qui
est l'école
alors avant de vous poser plus de
questions sur ça est-ce qu'il y a pas
aussi un autre lieu c'est les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que c'est pas les deux
lieux aujourd'hui où s'exprime de façon
plus majoritaire avec cette espèce de
force et qu'on a du mal à à juguler de
l'antisémitisme compliqué sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est que l'anonima
souvent permet beaucoup de choses même
si je dis souvent que ça n'est pas le le
cas c'est vrai que sur ce sujet-là ça
aide et
surtout dès que on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux que les messages se rapportent à
la réalité de la compréhension du
conflit là il y a des expression
antisémite beaucoup plus osée que
lorsque on se détache de ce sujet et
qu'on parle
des Juifs dans l'absol oui c'est c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites c'est que
euh le le le conflit est un prétexte
pour pouvoir avoir des propos qui ne
vont pas ne seront plus antisionistes à
cette époque à ce moment-là mais qui
seront carrément antisémite c'est un
prétexte à l'antisémitisme ex en tout
cas c'est l'antichambre l'expression
d'un antisémitisme qui va au-delà du
sujet de l'antisionisme et en plus comme
sur le conflit on voit bien que c'est
extrêmement polarisé que on a
une réalité de on avec un conflit qui
est qui est extrêmement enfin en tous
les cas qui qui soulève énormément de
passion énormément de passion et puis on
est loin du conflit de l'Ukraine contre
la Russie où quelque part l'Occident a
décidé qui était le méchant et qui était
le gentil en tout cas il est très clair
dans l'opinion public occidental qui est
soutenu là c'est beaucoup plus complexe
on a deux camps les uns et les autres
veulent se positionner et donc sont
extrêmement violent et là sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez une expression
polarisée et d'une violence extrême avec
en plus quelque chose de spécifique à ce
conflit qui a beaucoup de témoignages
beaucoup d'images qui sont souvent
détournées alors il y a énormément
d'internautes qui travaillent sur le
sujet et qui permet d'identifier les
détournements d'images mtenant quand
c'est un témoignage sans image c'est un
témoignage donc c'est compliqué de faire
la part des choses et là vous avez et le
posting ne favorise pas le contexte or
le contexte permet d'amener à la nuance
exactement
euh je reviens sur la la
manifestation je je reviens pas avant de
revenir sur la manifestation justement
sur une question parce qu'on en parlait
est-ce que justement cette présence de
l'antisémitisme à l'école elle elle se
perçoit à travers les réseaux sociaux
autrement dit est-ce que c'est ce que
vous percevez comme mouvement et quels
sont les mouvements qui vous permettent
de de confirmer que l'école est un lieu
où aujourd'hui et un des lieux où
s'exprime le avec force l'antisémitisme
quand on regarde les les réseaux sociaux
qui sont plus utilisés par les jeunes et
qui sont souvent utilisés par snapchat
Instagram Instagram TikTok voilà mais
mais surtout snap on voit bien que ce
sont des expressions qui étaient peu
utilisé il y avait énormément de
violence déjà il y avait des des
insultes et et on va dire des propos
quelque peu peu nuancés mais c'était pas
c'était relativement rarement sur ce
sujet là et là on voit bien que ça monte
donc on sent bien qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est en train de se passer sur
place
qui enfin en tout cas à l'école qui est
compliqué qui est très compliqué à
endiguer parce que de nouveau c'est pas
des expressions que je vais pas relayer
ici mais des expressions on voit bien
que le propos est clairement antisémite
là les choses sont plus nuancées et
c'est constamment des insinuations euh
des clichés
des des des voilà des images et des
rumeurs autour des gens de confession
juives qui sont relayés et qu'on pensait
avoir euh bon pensait qu'elles avveent
tout simplement disparu bien non la
jeune génération est en train de les
reprendre
euh une autre question donc c'est sur le
le consensus en tout cas que que
rencontre cette cette opinion ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tous les partis
toutes les tendances c'est que il y a
une polémique au niveau des dirigeants
politiques on a on est largement revenu
autour de de la France insoumise et du
rapport de la France insoumise à cette
mobilisation et en toutous les cas d'une
partie des dirigeants de la France
insoumise parce qu'on l' dit également
il y a une partie des des députés qui
ont eux manifesté à Strasbourg ce qui
est intéressant c'est que par contre
dans l'opinion quand on regarde le
sondage que vous avez fait avec odoxa et
qui est paru dans les dans l'édition
papier du Figaro de ce vendredi qui
était on peut retrouver sur le site du
Figaro ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tous les partis dans tous les partis il
y a une majorité pour soutenir cette
manifestation ce qui était intéressant
c'est qu'effectivement cette France
France insoumise et c'était surtout la
France insoumise c'était non parce que 7
Français sur 10 qui soutiennent la
marche dans l'absolu c'était étonnant
mais quand on voit aujourd'hui le le
nombre de personnes dans toutes les rues
en France on se dit que effectivement il
y avait ce soutien mais c'était 75 % des
des sympathisants LFI eux disait aussi
que ça c'était un sujet et qu'il le
soutenait et vous aviez même 75 % aussi
qui disait que ça ne voulait pas dire
qu'on soutenait le gouvernement
israélien lorsque l'on participait à
cette marche pour le PS c'était 84 %
pour les écolos 81 % donc on va dire que
il y avait effectivement un sujet d'une
forme de distance ou en tout cas de
décalage entre les politiques et les
personnalités politiques et la réalité
de la base des militants et des
sympathisants sur le terrain qui font
bien la différence entre les deux ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il soutiennent Israël
ça veut dire que l'antisémitisme pour
eux et que cette marche avait un vrai
sens alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ce sondage et avec ce que vous dites
montre que dites-moi si je me trompe
mais il y a un consensus dans l'opinion
comme le dit le professeur Pierre
birnebaum on l'abordit tout à l'heure
avec que George kusmanovic il y a un
moment il y a il y a des actes mais il
n'y a pas un pays antisémite c'est même
le contraire c'est c'est vraiment le
contraire on le voit aujourd'hui on le
voit aussi je vous dis dans les dans les
messages qui depuis ce matin sont
beaucoup plus forts pour pour dire non
il n'est pas question que
l'antisémitisme s'installe et voire même
certains qui commencent à dire bien à
nous aussi d'être vigilant nous citoyens
y compris sur les réseaux sociaux et de
plus traquer ses messages et de plus les
dénoncer et effectivement il y a il y a
vraiment une différence entre le
politique et la réalité sur le terrain
et et c'est un pays qui est contre
l'antisémitisme de façon fort
majoritaire y compris sur des des des
positions politiques qui sont un peu
différentes de celles qui sont exprimées
par par les politiques même par les
politiques et même notamment David
guireot moi je reviens sur cette sur
cette affaire parce que bon ça m un peu
échappé et en revanche j'ai vu que ça
tournait énormément sur les sur les sur
les sur les pas que moi aussi ça m'avait
un peu échappé et en préparant et c'est
là où on voit que ça appris énormément
sur les sur les réseaux sociaux là c'est
comment vous analysez ce genre de
phénomène just il y a il y a deux
raisons la première je vous disais tout
à l'heure que ce qui a SP de spécifique
c'est même important c'est l'utilité des
réseaux
sociauxation mais le le premier point
c'est je vous disais que les témoignages
sont partiement importants sur ce
conflit c'est-à-dire que chacun va
raconter et donné sa version et on n pas
toujours d'éléments factuels pour les
démontrer objectivement donc
effectivement c'est c'est très déroutant
et c'est d'autant plus déroutant que
chacun donne avec force conviction des
témoignages où on est enclin à à croire
et et à suivre ces témoignage donc ça
c'est une des premières explications la
deuxième c'est que on est en train de
parler de de d'une polémique absolument
ignoble sur des enfants sur un acte
horrible et que et bien chacun est
extrêmement outré c'est que comme
chacune des parties a l'impression que
l'autre est en train de faire quelque
chose de positivement ignoble donc vous
ne pouvez pas rester sans réagir et vous
avez sur les réseaux sociaux comme vous
le savez beaucoup de gens qui ne font
que se renseigner qui ne n'écrivent pas
qui ne partagent pas qui ne commentent
pas et qui pour cette affaire là se sont
sentis obligés de réagir tellement les
propos sont inérant parce que le débat
continue sur le chat du Figaro à l'heure
où on se parle et euh et je remercie P
ce temps les Internet les internautes de
de respecter vraiment le cadre de le
cadre de modération et de rester
vraiment de de de respecter les vraiment
les consignes de de de prudence et des
ch de modération ce sera bien pour tout
le monde mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que il y a ceux qui essayent de
justifier les propos de guireot non pas
de justifier l'horreur mais dire il a
voulu dire il a voulu dire ça il a pas
voulu dire ça c'est pas et et d'un autre
côté ceux qui disent oui mais dit ça
c'est que il veut
relativiser il veut relativiser les
actions du du Hamas c'est c'est les
termes du débat que vous observez
actuellementat de nouveau parce que vous
avez la réalité de témoignages qui ne
peuvent pas être avérés ou en tout cas
il y a pas d'élément factuel pour savoir
si c'est vrai ou pas pas d'élément
concrets et vous avez deux camps qui
sont extrêmement polarisés où
personne a une inter pardon je vous
coupe à une interpéation mais dit mais
il y en a un autre qui dit mais à ceux
qui défendent David guirud mais et le 7
octobre il s'est rien passé donc
vraiment le le débat porte sur ça et
c'est ce qu'on observe actuellement sur
les Réau c'est vraiment ça c'est c'est
un sujet de qui dit la vérité et je te
dis que moi j'ai vu mais qui a vu et je
n'ai pas d'éléments concrets et tous les
éléments concrets qui sont clairement
mis en avant et et et partagé par les
Israéliens sont systématiquement remis
en question commentés et à chaque fois
avec beaucoup de virulence parce que
comme on est sur des sujets extrêmement
violents et avec des images terribles
quand il y a des images et ou des
témoignages terribles quand il y a
témoignage c'est toujours dans l'extrême
vous ne pouvez pas simplement commenter
de façon modérée c'est forcément dans
l'extrême donc quand ce sont des propos
qui seraient pour essayer d'éclairer ou
de minimiser de témoignnage de de ce
monsieur bien forcément derrière vous
avez une surréaction qui est liée à la
violence de ce que l'on est en train
d'évoquer quoi ce qui est vrai c'est que
dans les propos de guot il y a rien qui
dit euh ce qui est frappant c'est qu' ne
fait pas d'allusion au aux attaques du 7
mars donc il a il y a une vraiment on
est au cœur de l'ambiguité ben on est au
cœur de la complexité de quelque chose
qui est je l'ai dit et et et je peux
redonner une interprétation sur ce que
j'ai dit alors que en fait on peut
présupposer que c'était pas ça qu'
qu'elle avait envie d'exprimer au début
je reviens sur la question de la la
mobilisation on voit donc ce soir que la
mobilisation et et au rendez-vous on GTE
encore une fois les les chiffres he mais
enfin en tout cas les images sont assez
frappantes et les témoignages et les les
contte-rendus sont sont assez frappants
et ce que disait à l' tout à l'heure
Vincent roseron ce que disent également
nos euh oui nos confrères de la FP
néanmoins d'ailleurs Jean-Luc mélenchan
lui vient de s'exprimer et estime que la
marche contre l'antisémitisme a été un
échec toute la droite et l'extrême
droite pourtant uni ont échoué à
reproduire les mobilisations générales
du du passé pour l'instant on n'est pas
on n pas encore des des résultats dans S
pil allait dire que c'était une réussite
c'est sans doute effectivement en tous
les cas c'est pas ce qu'il a dit euh je
reviens justement bon là sans sans
préjuger de signes on a plutôt quand
même le signe que c'est quel le la
mobilisation a étit au rendez-vous euh
mais là on est euh on tourne un peu
autour de cette question là depuis le
début de notre discussion Véronique
c'est que on était sur un une
mobilisation euh contre l'antisémitisme
donc contre une un phénomène mais qui
n'est pas enfin phénomène c'est pas
c'est pas lié à une affaire concrète
c'est lié au à la multiplication d'actes
antisémites et cetera et est-ce que le
danger justement sur une mobilisation
comme ça qui permet de dire ça à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon encore une fois on n'
pas encore les chiffres et que
visiblement ces propos risque peut-être
en tous les cas d'être démenti par
d'autres et PE et semble-t-il
semble-t-il semble-t-il semble-t-il
peut-être par la réalité non néanmoins
est-ce que des faits divers comme la
séquestration et l'assassinat d'Ilan
Alimi en 2006 ou bien l'assassinat de
Miriel knon ne suscite pas
plus la la la compassion immédiate le
soutien la mobilisation immédiate oui
oui comme
Carpentra les engagements dans l'opinion
ça suscite sur le moment plus parce que
de nouveau ça n'est pas lié à quelque
chose qui est compliqué dès que on a
ramené la marche d'aujourd'hui au sujet
du conflit on a quelque chose qui est
plus complexe parce que on a
l'impression qu'il faut se positionner
sur le conflit en revanche quand on ne
parle que de l'antisémitisme personne
n'est pour l'antisémitisme donc de fait
vous avez un mouvement général et vous
avez une sympathie pour pour le le le
peuple juif de de fait et pour les gens
de confessions juifs qui n'ont pas à
subir les attaques infammes qu'il
subissent personne ne peut être pour ça
donc en fait vous avez une réalité d'un
mouvement de fond qui dès que c'est
dissocié du conflit ça ça ça mobilise
plus donc effectivement les exemples que
vous avez cité ont sur le moment suscité
plus de réactions et là aujourd'hui ce
qui a fait aussi que les gens descendent
dans la rue ce sont tous les l'addition
de de tous les actes qu'on a vu sur le
territoire français les étoiles qui sont
taguées sur les murs oui alors
précisément c'est une question que je
voulais vous poser parce que on a vu ces
ces étoiles de David dont on narrive pas
à savoir qui les
a voilà exactement et euh d'un autre
côté euh on arri on a du mal à alors
maintenant il commence à avoir des des
infos qui remontent mais à à voir quels
ont été les les quelle a été la nature
des des actes antisémite qui ont été
commis et donc est-ce que là c'était pas
là le le risque de justement d'avoir une
un désengagement de l'opinion à ce
moment-là la réalité c'est que si vous
avez des des des éléments et on va en
avoir de plus en plus et le nombre de
signalements qu'il y a depuis le 7
octobre qui ne fait que grandir est un
signe aussi euh plus vous allez avoir
des actes qui sont concrets et qui sont
sur le territoire français et qui sont
totalement dissociés de la réalité de ce
qui peut se passer au Moyen-Orient et
bien là vous avez une mobilisation
d'opinion publ systématique donc
l'histoire des fameuses étoiles tagué
c'est quelque chose de concret même s'il
y a une polémique pour savoir si fait
qu'elle soit bleue ou pas bleu soit un
soutien ou pas un soutien vous avez
c'est cette une famille qui a été
attaquée et qui a raconté l'horreur de
de de l'agression qu'ils ont eu vous
avez des phrases et des insign tion
constante et le fait que les Français de
confession juif qui se qui disent je ne
peux plus mettre la mesusa je ne peux
plus mettre de signe extérieur j'ai peur
de donner mon prénom sont bien la
démonstration d'une espèce de montée
l'attente de la frayeur de des uns et
des autres et des petits signes
d'antisémitisme quotidien donc ce sont
ces élémentsl qui vont faire que les
Français vont se mobiliser j'invite les
internautes un petit peu à calmer à
modérer leur langage notamment Charles
et adld parce que là ça vire parfois à
l'insulte donc pas d' pas de juron s'il
vous plaît sur le chat et
euh cha on est des des arguments une
disputation comme on dit en latin oui
une dispute non donc merci de respecter
ce
euh cette ces éléments de la charte de
modération de euh de du Figaro sans quoi
bah on sera obligé de bannir euh et ce
serait dommage euh on revient sur cette
mobilisation énormément encore de monde
euh actuellement quels sont les
d'ailleurs les mots clés les tendances
sur les sur sur les réseaux en tout cas
les mots clés qui vivent la France
beaucoup pour la France ouais ouais pour
la France euh et et et globalement il y
a pas mal de commentaires qui sont
explosés par lieu vous avez beaucoup de
messages aussi autour de LFI antisémite
euh quelques messages sur Madame
Tondelier et beaucoup de
messages qui a sur Marine Tondelier qui
est présente hein à cette manifestation
au côté de Fabien Roussel et d'Olivier
fort et bien la réalité de de sa
présence qui fait parler en soi le fait
qu'elle y soit tout simplement le fait
queelle se soit qu'elle soit avec
Olivier fort et Fabien Roussel fait
beaucoup parler et et pose la réalité de
sa position euh face au mouvement la
position aussi des écolos euh voilà
globalement c'est plutôt salué euh
plutôt apprécié elle est souvent
associée à la réalité de voilà de de ce
qu'il fallait faire euh l'attitude que
les politiques devaient avoir en soit
donc c'est plutôt positif pour elle euh
l'autre et dans les autres hashtags qui
montent évidemment la marche contre
l'antisémitisme et la marche du 12
novembre sont les deux mots clés les
plus repris à plusieurs millions de
messages plusieurs millions de de
messages donc c'est ce qui fait le buzz
ce soir sur les sur les réseaux ouais de
loin de loin et pas seulement sur
Twitter enfin sur X
x c'est pas c'est pas si révélateur que
ça enfin X est très
particulier les on va dire que sur
Facebook sur Instagram son les réseaux
massifs hein aujourd'hui oui vraiment là
il y a un certain nombre de de partage
donc de ce point de vue là la
mobilisation est un succès et c'est
plutôt un succès je regardais sur
facebook beaucoup de partag des images
un peu partout en
France voilà après vous avez évidemment
les hashtag autour de l'extrême qui sont
pas
forcément très sympathique et qui sont
l'extrême à droite comme à gauche
d'ailleurs mais c'est voilà c'est
souvent ceux que vous allez plus voir
parce que vos algorithmes ont les
poussés mais en volume global quand je
regarde c'est pas ceux-là qui sont le
plus utilisés alors affluence on attend
les les chiffres mais en tous les cas
les gens sans attendre les chiffres qui
sont présents dans la manifestation se
disent eux heureux de l'affluence c'est
en tout cas ce qu'on peut lire dans le
live texte du Figaro avec une ambiance
ou au cœur du cor on peut lire qu'il y a
une ambiance calme et peu de
slogan les gens se disent heureux Axel
notamment qualifie l'atmosphère de
géniale bienveillante respectueuse et
puis il n'y a pas que des Juifs c'est ce
qu'on a vu l'EUR Estelle qui se
définissait comme comme acté até pardon
et boulevard Saint-Michel on on voyait
une ambiance selon un manif une
manifestante bonne enfant patriote tout
le monde a chanté la Marseillaise et
c'est vrai que c'est parti
des images de cet après-midi les tris
marseillaises qui ont été chanté à
chaque fois avec un cortège une tête de
cortège qui s'arrêtait les la première
ministre deux anciens présidents de la
République le président de l'Assemblée
le président du Sénat et la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale avec également
les responsables religieux qui
marchaient côte à côte en tous les cas
de la communauté juive et de l'Église
catholique certaines certains appels
visblement à la dispersion de la
manifestation effectivement la la place
et mon rant à Paris est assez est assez
petite donc ça on doit pas pouvoir
effectivement mettre plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes si on arrive à
mettre plusieurs milliers de personnes
c'est c'est
effectivement pas mal il y a également B
vous êtes nombreux à nous suivre sur le
le compte Youtube du du Figaro si vous
voulez partager des commentaires tout en
respectant les consignes de modération
vous allez également sur le site du
Figaro où vous pouvez le faire et euh
nous pouvons répondre à vos à vos
commentaires euh effectivement l'
rappelle également que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour lui estime que c'est un
échec pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
chiffres mais il y a des images il y a
des témoignages qui font état d'une
grande affluence à Paris une grande
affluence
également en région c'est surtout
important qu'il y ait plein de nonom
Juifs c'est ce que dit euh Ava 17 ans et
Géraldine Sam mère qui ont été rencontré
par des
euh journalistes du Figaro au-delà du
fait euh que je me sens juif je me sens
très française déclare Ava je n'ai pas
peur dans la vie de tous les jours mais
je prends quand même plus de précautions
depuis le 7 octobre j'évite au maximum
de prendre des taxis car même si je ne
porte pas de signe d'un d'un distinctif
j'ai un nom de famille juif euh ça c'est
on le disait tout à l'heure euh
Véronique c'est c'est une peur et c'est
un phénomène en tous les cas pas
quantifié mais en tout cas qui remonte
notamment dans les en en tout cas c'est
c'est nouveau sur les réseau des
témoignages de ce type là c'est assez
nouveau il y en a toujours eu sans doute
mais pour qu'il remonte de façon massive
sur les outils d'analyse et de
massification c'est que oui c'est
important euh et c'est assez nouveau et
surtout ce qui est nouveau c'est ce
sentiment qu'il faut cacher euh à tout
prix euh pour éviter soit une agression
soit à tout le moins une une polémique
en tout cas il y a une réalité qui est
euh depuis le 7 octobre ou ça monte
c'est intéressant parce que
euh c'est un phénomène qu'on a commencé
à observer au début des années 2000 avec
notamment en S la crainte de de
plusieurs personnes de plusieurs foyers
ceux qui voulaient repartir vivre qui
qui voulaiit partir vivre en Israël qui
ont fait l'alia ou bien avec des propos
d'ailleurs quelques années plus tard de
Benyamin netanou qui avait suscité pas
mal de de polémiques mais appelant les
les jues de France à faire l'alia et
d'être il se sentir en plus en sécurité
en Israël ce qu'il avait déclaré à
l'époque mais également en tous les cas
on avait vu un déplacement d'un certain
nombre de de personnes de confession
juive qui quittaient progressivement la
Sainton notamment pour aller plus au
nord dans l'Ouest dans dans dans l'Oise
notamment et c'est c'est en tout cas on
a on retrouve encore ces mots
aujourd'hui donc c'est quand même ça
prouve que malgré les mobilisations
malgré les discours les les choses ont
pas complètement changé et bien au
contraire non alors les mobil tion et
les discours on aimerait que ça suffise
mais c'est en tout cas un signe fort ça
permet de se sentir moins seul ça permet
de donner le sentiment que il y a une
cohésion derrière vous mais
malheureusement c'est pas une marche qui
va changer le quotidien non plus c'est
l'accumulation et des marches et des
pétitions et des signes de soutien moi
je trouve que cet après-midi dans ce que
j'ai pu voir sur les réseaux quand les
internautes se disent que ils vont être
eux-mêmes vigilants signaler encore plus
et qu'il faut absolument rien lâcher
autour de l'antisémitisme et que lorsque
l'antisémitisme s'exprime sur les
réseaux il faut le signaler et il faut
être tous derrière c'est sans doute un
des moyens les plus efficaces aussi pour
lutter contre l'antisémitisme en plus
d'une marche nationale où beaucoup de
gens seront présents on va essayer de
retrouver Vincent roseron qui lui doit
être maintenant dans la nuit comme le
sont tous les manifestants
euh ce qui se trouve encore sur les
boulevards Saint-Michel et boulevard
Saint-Germain à à Paris euh Vincent quel
est où en êtes-vous et et quel est
l'ambiance autour de vous on on parle
d'une ambiance
silencieuse selon la formule consacrée
bon enfant également est-ce que c'est le
cas alors que vous apparemment vous êtes
à côté de Saint-Germain des
prê exactement je me trouve à
Saint-Germain des prês nous venons de
passer devant euh vous voyez la tour
Monparnasse qui est au fond ici euh nous
continuons nous continuons sur notre
route alors la pluie elle est arrivée
dans la manifestation et euh tout est
beaucoup plus dégarni il y a beaucoup
plus de gens qui ont quitté la
manifestation pour ne pas aller au bout
même si vous le voyez sur ces images il
y a quand même encore pas mal de monde
euh qui sont présents toujours euh en
train de défiler vous disez sur les
slogans très peu effectivement de
slogans beaucoup d'appludissement eu
quelques marseillaises et euh je pense
que le slogan qu'on entend le plus c'est
libérer les otages qui revient le plus
souvent ici
ouis al ça c'est intéressant merci
beaucoup Vincent et on continue de de
suivre ça avec vous on espère avoir
également des des témoignages de de
manifestants on recueillera avant de de
clôturer ce live le
le on a quand même passé l'après-midi à
dire on n'est pas sur une marche compte
on distingue les deux situations mais
enfin la question des otages revient
alors ça c'est intéressant parce
que sur sur un autre point sur par
rapport au point qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure
Véronique je reviens je dis
yalim knol
lesotage est-ce que il y a pas justement
un sentiment oui ça c'est sûr c'est pas
pareil c'est his c'est c'est sont des
drames différents des tragédies
différentes mais est-ce que là aussi
c'est pas ça aussi
qui ça joue joue un rôle il y a un rôle
il y a il y a en tous les cas un un
phénomène
d'identification et de compassion qui
qui s'opè alors oui de compassion
forcément parce que dans les otages je
rappelle que cette fois-ci il y a quand
même des enfants des tout petits enfants
que ça fait déjà 30 jours que les
familles sont très actives pour qu'on
les oublie pas parce que c'est le risque
principal il partage des photos des
vidéos des des des histoires enfin voilà
pour pour bien incarner la ité de leur
présence mais ça n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose quand je vous disais que
la marche aujourd'hui elle devait se
dissocier de la réalité du conflit sur
place même si tout le monde soutient la
réalité de la libération des otages il
n'y a pas de question et et même au
milieu des polémiques personne n'a envie
de dire que les otages doivent être
sacrifiés bien évidemment mais ça n'est
ça n'est pas tout à fait le même sujet
et la compassion même si elle est là
c'est une compassion et il y a une
expression qui est horrible qui ait à
chaque fois des des victimes innocentes
mais des victimes par essence elles sont
innocentes ou si c'est ou alors ça
voudrait dire qu'elle est victimes
coupable enfin je cette expression elle
n'a pas de sens donc évidemment les
otages personne n'imagine que il ne faut
pas les soutenir il ne faut pas faire
des choses pour pour pour aider à leur
libération mais la marche de cet
après-midi n'était pas liée à ce
sujet-là donc j'entends que visiblement
dans dans les cortèges on en parle de
plus en plus je il faudrait que je
regarde si on en parle plus ce soir sur
les réseaux mais c'était pas forcément
ça le sujet même si de nouveau euh
aujourd'hui il y a l'expression globale
autour des des otages elle est elle est
en soutien il y a un autre phénomène de
cet après-midi que personne ne conteste
en tous les cas nous c'est ce qu'on a pu
observer ici et c'est ce que rapporent
également les les aussi bien les
journalist du Figaro qui sont sur place
Vincent Roson qui est dans le cortège
également nos confrères de de la FP euh
qui nous alimentent en dépêche euh il y
a énormément de de calme dans cette
manifestation est-ce que ce calme est
également euh ressort sur les réseaux et
en tous les cas le alors les réseaux
sont pas calmes sur la question mais
est-ce que le calme quiil y a dans la
manifestation est un est un phénomène
qui ressort de que je vous disais que
globalement on a quand même cet
après-midi pas mal de de messages autour
de trouvons des moyens pour apaiser la
situation dans le trouvons des moyens
pour apaiser la situation les uns et les
autres disant mais il va falloir être
plus vigilant signaler euh plus les les
les paroles les messages les photos les
insinuations qui sont antisémites ça
veut bien dire que les uns et les autres
ont envie de faire quelque chose et cet
après-midi même les hashtags étaient
plutôt et et les mots clés puisqu'il
faut dire mots clés maintenant les mots
diis c'est ça euh était plus autour de
la marche elle-même que sur des mots
polémiques ce qui est souvent un
indicateur pour dire est-ce que le ton
est est compliqué ou pas ou est-ce que
c'est c'est un sujet de Battle non cet
après-midi en tout cas quand vous
regardiez en particulier sur facebook
même s'il y a toujours des gens qui sont
énervés qui sont la polémique he mais
globalement c'était du partage d'images
euh et le fait que les uns et les autres
se réjouissaient que ça se passe un peu
partout dans le calme sans slogan
particulièrement euh avec plutôt la
Marseillaise et plutôt beaucoup beaucoup
de ouais on va dire de de jovialité les
uns avec les autres l'introduction du
conflit israëlo-palestinien en France
n'a pas sa place c'est ce qu'a affirmé
euh le secret secréire premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste Olivier
fort qui était présent au côté de marine
Tondelier et de Fabien Roussel à cette
manifestation on ne peut pas être tenu
responsable sur ce qui se passe en
Israël quand on est juif a-t-il aussi
déclaré et à se battre pour qu'il n ait
jamais de confission organisée la
République ne peut se satisfaire du
moindre crime antisémite nous sommes ici
massivement présent quel que soit notre
couleur politique et ça aussi c'est
effectivement un des phénomènes de cette
de de cet après-midi et de cette
mobilisation ouais sachant que restera
quand même quelque chose qui était
l'ensemble des positions politique qu'il
y a eu avant la marche on voit bien que
les Français ont peu apprécier et que ça
ça sera retenu et globalement si les
chiffres sont excellents ça ne sera pas
mis au compte des politiques et si les
chiffres sont mauvais ça leors sera
mis ça sera ça sera de leur faute donc
globalement les politiques n'ont pas
marqué des points dans cette alors si
les politiques n'avaient pas été
présents est-ce que ils auraient marqué
des points je ne pense pas non plus ils
se sont mis dans une position fort
compliquée donc globalement on va dire
que parce que c'est une manifestation à
l'appel quand même de politique qui a
été faite à la différence des
précédentes manifestations à l'appel de
deux politiques qui se présentent dans
leur fonction plus que dans leur
position de de de de Partisan donc
c'était un sujet effectivement est-ce
que le président enfin voilà le Sénat et
la l'Assemblée nationale ce sont deux
fonctions ce sont pas de politiques en
soi et qui représentent la nation
française donc ça pouvait avoir un sens
c'est l'ensemble des polémiques qu' a eu
autour qui font que un moment donné les
Français se sont dit où va-t-on et on
voyait bien dans le ce qu'on avait fait
pour Le Figaro les Français avaient
envie d'autre chose que d'un débat
politique et de politique petite
politique politicienne de comme Paul
comme on dit ou de popol voilà c'était
pas ça le sujet donc je pense que
effectivement s'il n'y avait pas été ça
été compliqué mais globalement après ces
polémiques quoi qu'il se passe ça ne
sera pas mis à leur compte s'il y a un
succès et ça sera mis à leur à leur
compte à l'inverse si les chiffres ne
sont pas aussi élevés mais il semblerait
à mon avis qu'ils vont être plutôt
élevés le politique qui est plus
décricrié par rapport à tout ça c'est
c'est qui c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon clairement clairement
ouais ouais et on voit bien 75 % des des
sympathisants et les filles qui
considéraient queil fallait soutenir
cette marche on voit bien qu'il y a un
décalage entre la base et la réalité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon après ça veut pas
dire que euh il ne tient pas euh euh
elle est fi ça ne veut pas dire que euh
il a il a en si grande difficulté que ça
mais ça veut dire quand même qu'il y a
un décalage très net entre ses positions
et la réalité de sa base on va continuer
à suivre cette cette manifestation et
qui est en train d'arriver euh euh à son
à son terme en tous les cas euh la la la
tête la tête du cortège est arrivée il y
a environ 1h 1h30 euh à il y a 1 heure
pardon euh à au niveau de la place
Edmond Rostan à côté du Palais du
Luxembourg qui est le siège du Sénat qui
est la point d'arrivée de cette
mobilisation mais une mobilisation qui a
euh euh appelé en où il y a eu
énormément de monde euh en tous les cas
énormément de monde qui continuaient
d'arriver alors même que le cortège
était parti depuis depuis longtemps et
donc ce qui explique encore la présence
de pas mal de personnes dans la rue même
si euh c'est la nuit euh on va essayer
de voir justement euh Vincent roseron
est-ce que euh les les manifestants
commencent à partir ils vont manifester
jusqu'au
bout et bien écoutez pour l'instant
alors je me suis abrité un peu parce
qu'il pleut pas mal là en ce moment mais
euh vous voyez sur ces images ils
continuent de passer euh ils ne sont pas
encore arrivés euh par rapport au à
l'endroit où on de où par rapport au
Sénat mais certains continuent d'avancer
il y a aussi pas mal de gens qui
s'arrête avec la pluie forcément des
gens qui font qui Bifur vous voyez le le
cortège est beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins dense que c que en début de
manifestation que voilà pendant 1 heure
et quart vous dites que le que le que
que le corortel est arrivé il y a il y a
plus d'une heure nous on n pas on est
parti parti très très tard par rapport à
ça le le què est resté bloqué aussi 1
heure aux Invalides montrant
effectivement qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de monde à cette
manifestation effectivement beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de monde on entend encore
les les chiffres on va continuer à
suivre ça avec avec vous Vincent on va
faire un plein pot sur les images qui
nous parviennent soit ici au niveau de
l'Odéon soit au niveau de la de la place
Edmond Rostan en tous les cas de ceux
qui s'en rapprochent et on vous tient au
courant dès que nous allons les les
chiffres qui doivent en tous les cas
nous guettons les chiffres je sais pas
s'ils doivent tomber mais en tous les
cas nous les nous les guettons avec
intérêt surtout que c'est devenu
apparemment une une nouvelle polémique
et puis les déclarations qui
peuvent encore avoir
lieu alors que effectivement l'essentiel
des déclarations des des personnalités
politiques ont été ont été tenu à
l'arrivée du du cortège mais il y a
également l'arrivée
du les autres responsables politiques
les responsables politiques des
républicains notamment Eric sootti les
les responsables politiques comme les
responsables de la de la gauche on a
parlé tout à l'heure d'Olivier fort
marine Tondelier et Fabien Roussel et
également les responsables politiques du
rassemblement national avec une forte
délégation qui était conduite tout à
l'heure par Marine Le Pen où se
trouvait à côté de laquelle se trouvait
Vincent reeron je vous laisse pour
l'instant avec ces images on continue de
les suivre on continue de les vivre et
on se retrouve très vite pour commenter
les dernières
infos êes Lee de la fin
[Musique]
laestation
m messieurs vous êtes sur le lieu de la
fin de la manifestation vous pouvez vous
disperser par les différents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
actes tous les sont ouvert les VP
all mes messieurs vous êtes sur le lieu
de la fin de la manifestation vous
pouvez quitter les lieux par les
différents axes le est
ouvert
messieurs vous êtes sur le lieu de la
fin de la
manifestation quit les lieux par les
différentses est
ouver
et Messieurs la manifestation est
terminée ne tapz pas sur la place
merci mieur vous êtes sur le lieu de la
la manifestation vous pvez quitter les
lieux par les différents axes le est
ouvert
messieurs vous êtes sur le lieu de la de
la manifestation PZ quit les lieux par
les
différ
manestation
[Musique]
différ
[Applaudissements]
a
[Musique]
ageageageérérér
républer
républ
mesdames et messieux merci deter la
place c'est la fin de la
[Applaudissements]
manifestation fin la
manifestation pour permettre au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
duavant
[Applaudissements]
manest
[Musique]
de la
manifestation la
placeou
ur vous sur le lieu de la fin de la
manifestation vous pouvez quitter la
place par les différents
actes
mieurs vous êtes sur le la manifestation
merci la place
différ
là vous êtes sur le lieu de la fin de la
manifestation vous pouvez quitter la
place par les différents actes le est
[Musique]
ouverte messieur vous êtes sur le lieu
de la fin de la manifestation merci de
quitter la place par les différents
actes le est
ouvert vous êtes sur le lieu de la fin
de la manifestation vous pouvez quitter
la place par les différents actes
et Mesdames et Messieurs la
manifestation est terminée merci de
quitter la
place les métos et les
pour Lee de de la manifestation c la
place par les
différents
messieur vous êtes sur le lie de la
manifestation merci de quit la place par
les
différents
[Applaudissements]
messieur vous êtes sur le lieun la
manifestation merci de la place par les
différentsch
êes sur le lie de la la manifestation
merci de quitter la place sur les
différents
axesouver
ur vous êtes sur le lie de la fin de la
manifestation merci de quitter la
place
ieur sur le lie de la
manifestation la
place
b le lie de la fin de la manifestation
merci deit la place les différ
Act
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
libértan
libertan
liberan
avec
[Musique]
m messieur vous êtes sur le lieu de la
fin de la manifestation et on qué la
place par les différents actes le H est
ouvert allons enfant de la
PAT le jour de
gloire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lesous dansre
[Musique]
campagneér se il VI jusque
la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mar
messieurs vous êtes sur le lieu de la
fin de la manifestation merciit la place
par les différents actes
récou
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
nous nous
unis
avec combat
a combat
b République en
Der att République en
Der
répu
R
de
[Musique]
juif attaqué République en danger voilà
les slogans qu'on vient d'entendre et
voilà les slogans qu'on a pu entendre
cet après-midi dans une ambiance calme
dans une ambiance silencieuse dans une
ambiance en tous les cas plutôt paisible
euh le chiffre vient de tomber 105000
personnes à Paris selon la préfecture de
police ce sont les premières
informations les premiers chiffres 7500
à Marseille également personnes qui ont
été mobilisées voilà les premiers
chiffres on va retrouver Vincent roseron
qui lui se trouve à la fin de la
manifestation avec deux personnes qui
ont participé Vincent
hein alors oui
je
oui effectivement je suis avec Christine
qui a participé à cette manifestation
alors pourquoi c déjà important de venir
pour vous aujourd'hui parce que je suis
contre
l'antisémitisme et que il faut soutenir
les Juifs et qu'il faut soutenir
Israël il y a il y a eu 150 105000
personnes aujourd'hui dans la rue
d'après les chifes de préfecture qu'on
vient de qu'on vient d'apprendre est-ce
est-ce que vous trouvez justement que
que ce que que ce
que que c'était
bien je sais pas enfin a beaucoup de
monde on a vu beaucoup de monde
maintenant il faut faut soutenir c'est
notre c'est pour tout le monde que ça
soit pour les Juifs pour les chrétiens
c'est pour tout le
monde vous êtes vous êtes vraiment senti
soutenu lors de cette lors de cette
marche il y avait une une ambiance calme
on l'a ditation tout à fait oui tout à
fait très très bien et non non pour moi
tout était très bien il fallait que je
sois là trè bien nous soyons là aussi
parce que faut soutenir les gens qui
sont qui font partie de la France et qui
se sont battu pour la France faut pas
les oubli et qui sont dans le cimetière
donc voilà moi je suis venue pour ça
voilà bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec
nous merci beaucoup Vincent et merci ce
témoignage ce dernier témoignage cette
manifestation 105000 personnes vcent moi
je vais vous poser la dernière question
puisque on va va clôturer ce live même
si on va rester laisser les les
dernières images les images de cette de
cette
mobilisation qu'est-ce que d'abord
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de cette de
cet après-midi vous qui
étz sur
place effectivement il y avait beaucoup
de monde tout au long de cette
manifestation on aurait pu penser que il
y aurait que qu'il y aurait pas autant
de gens mais vous on l'a montré tout au
long de la journée il y a eu énormément
de de de gens la manifestation a mis
énormément de temps à partir les
problèmes de réseau bah forcément c'est
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de gens et
vous disiez aussi l'ambiance calme
malgré quelques tensions à cause ou euh
avec les politiques en tout cas le
rassemblement national par exemple qui a
été hué à certains moment euh les
marine Tondelier Olivier fort et Fabien
Roussel eux aussi ont pu être conrués
mais sinon c'est une ambiance calme des
applaudissements des marseillaises qui
ont été chantés une une manifestation
qui s'est déroulée donc dans le
calme une manifestation qui s'est
déroulé dans le calme qui a réuni 105000
personnes selon la préfecture de police
de de Paris merci beaucoup Vincent de
nous avoir fait vivre justement ces ces
instants cette manifestation qui est en
train donc d'arriver ici placé de
monrostan à Paris je vous donne les
dernières informations vous pouvez les
avoir également sur le sur le live text
du Figaro le président du CRIF qui
regrette l'absence d'Emmanuel Macron
alors absence qui était défendu tout à
l'heure par georgees kousmanovic qui
était l'ancien conseiller de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon donc pas franchement un ami
politique d'Emmanuel Macron c'est peu de
le dire mais qui disait que avec un
certain nombre de
personnalités les plus hautes
personnalités de l'État le 2è la deuxè
personne de l'État en la présence de
Gérard Larché la 3e en la personne de
yel Bron pivé et euh la présence de la
première ministre ellisabeth born ça
justifiait peut-être aussi que le
président soit à l'écart c'était en tout
cas la thèse de George kusmanovic en
tous les cas ça n'a pas suffi à
convaincre Jonathan Harfi qui sera notre
invité d'ailleurs je vous le signale
demain en direct à 17h15 pour dans le
cadre de l'émission point de vue euh
Emmanuel Macron qui a par ailleurs écrit
une lettre donct vous pouvez retrouver
le le texte sur le site du Figaro la
police donc disperse euh nous sommes les
1 % jwish lives matter c'est un des
slogans que l'on pouvait entendre et que
l'on pouvait voir également sur euh lors
de de cette manifestation tous les infos
toutes les images sont à retrouver sur
bien entendu le site du Figaro ce live
est à revivre à la également sur Youtube
la page Youtube du Figaro un grand merci
à ceux qui l'ont modéré un grand merci
également à ceux qui ont permis son son
organisation et sa tenue tout au long de
l'après-midi euh je remercie Riad beckir
Virginie lerionnaire Victor Griset et
bien sûr Vincent reoseron sur place euh
et
euh effectivement l'équipe des les
réseaux sociaux qui continuent de
modérer on vous laisse avec ces images
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain pour l'info à partir de
18h 17h point de vue également la
question du jour à partir de 16h et le
buzz TV 18h bienvenue en Île-de-France
19h le club Le Figaro international avec
Philippe Gelli ce sera également à 20h
et bien sûr un live dès que l'actualité
l'exige c'est le principe même sur le
site du Figaro merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivi et on vous laisse en direct
avec ces
[Musique]
images
vhicu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]